[SPEAKER_03]: Remember to record.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm recording already.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Because last time, I think, last time I forgot because basically we were hanging around for a while before we actually started playing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so I'm like, oh, I'll hold off on recording until we actually start.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's one song in this playlist that was really out of place that came up last time.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then it was like, like this is supposed to be a relatively like chill, sort of dramatic playlist.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there was a battle music somewhere in this playlist.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I might just skip through it if I can find it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think this is also very melancholy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, would you know that the playlist is called Melancholy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, so I'm glad.
[SPEAKER_02]: This song is an AI generated song called Theoside that I made for the campaign.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, yeah, it was this one.
[SPEAKER_03]: How dare you do AI-generated things, Crimson?
[SPEAKER_03]: I would never do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who would dare?
[SPEAKER_03]: I read through the player brief you gave us before the episode 1 and I forgot so many things.
[SPEAKER_01]: I probably forgot something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most likely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see what this playlist is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quite a lot of the songs are from the Critical Role animated series soundtrack.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're all kind of like good for, I guess, made for D&D type of scenarios.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wonder why.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, technically it's just a TV show, not
[SPEAKER_02]: Not the D&D session.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's like, if you talk about critical role, everyone's going to be like, oh, D&D.
[SPEAKER_05]: My mom finally is able to say DD when she asks me, how did your DB go?
[SPEAKER_05]: That's close enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two out of three letters, correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I mean, at least she knows what it's about and she didn't mess it up with another double D. Yeah, my mom doesn't know what it means either, but my dad and sister knows and they heard me playing and they were both like, you fucking nerd.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember when we started playing years ago, my little brother called me a nerd, and now he's playing D&D himself.
[SPEAKER_02]: Got him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fucking nerd.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've run Candela campaigns for my parents, my brother, for Christmas and stuff we've done in the last couple of years.
[SPEAKER_05]: I did a one shot with my brother and sister and my brother's girlfriend last year.
[SPEAKER_05]: They really liked it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I'm also DMing at work.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think they found out about I mean, there's a few people at work who are into D&D and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: And when I joined the company, they were like, Oh, what are your interests and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I said D&D as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then the company is just trying to do a lot of like,
[SPEAKER_02]: uh, like team building stuff, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like they, they did like a, like they've got a book club going because it's a remote company, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: They want people to like make friends with each other because you don't see each other.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so yeah, one of the suggestions was D&D.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to be running D&D like one shots, I guess for the European time zone people at my work.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just kind of interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where's the company located that you work for?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's completely remote.
[SPEAKER_02]: The office is in Delaware in the US, which I'm pretty sure is just for tax reasons.
[SPEAKER_02]: But about 50% of the company is US and 50% is EU.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think a lot of the C-suite, like the CEO and stuff, are all Canadian.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think technically it would be Canadian, but just registered in the US for the benefits there, and then it's international anyway.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, makes sense in that kind of environment.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also work in an ICT lab and in a game team.
[SPEAKER_03]: So there's so many people playing D&D.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also played like one shots in a Finnish campaigns and I'm going to actually start the Finnish campaign or participate as a player this year.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's fun.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a nice activity to do if you want to
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's also nice to play in your own language because it's so much easier, but not that it would be better, but it's just different.
[SPEAKER_05]: I felt that it was a little bit of cringe to do it in Dutch.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I thought the same.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess you don't get much like.
[SPEAKER_02]: like fantasy stuff in your language that is made in in like Dutch or in Finnish right I guess they dub stuff sure but like yeah there's probably not that much stuff that's written in Dutch for the Dutch audience of like fantasy so I guess a lot of children's books maybe sure yeah oh yeah you can do a Moomin campaign I mean that's the only you know Moomins are Billy (Billiam)?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, uh, it's like the classic it's the number one finish export when it comes to children's television What's the dutch name for movement?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh thinking about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Holy shit It's kind of like a little bit dark it's quite cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's uh, it's to watch it when there was a kid never seen it no idea what it is, I guess it just depends whether it made it onto tv in
[SPEAKER_02]: Netherlands right but in the UK it was like shown like dubbed into English but cool um so I think most people in the UK know about it and associate Finland with the movement yeah Torviansu
[SPEAKER_05]: It's a bit like Studio Ghibli.
[SPEAKER_05]: A Finnish writer but it was released in Swedish.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a Finnish-Swedish writer.
[SPEAKER_03]: She lived in Finland.
[SPEAKER_03]: The animation itself is made in Japan actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well that's why it's kind of Studio Ghibli.
[SPEAKER_02]: They have it in the Helsinki airport.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's famous enough that they consider it to be internationally recognized, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then there's a German one, Sturm in Momental.
[SPEAKER_05]: Classic.
[SPEAKER_05]: Jesus Christ.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess in the 90s, there were episodes
[SPEAKER_05]: that were translated to Dutch.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just watched Pokemon.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also watched Pokemon and movies.
[SPEAKER_01]: No Pokemon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dragon Ball Z was my thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: So much of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I never watched Dragon Ball Z.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you watch Digimon?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: as well, but it has the worst Finnish dub.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's the worst in history.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we've actually seen even clips of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's so bad.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have watched them like a few years ago in Hangout Discord, like we linked them there.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'd say in general, the Dutch dubs for children's shows are pretty good.
[SPEAKER_01]: but they often have like women doing the children voices which i guess is common everywhere but no yeah i remember the pokemon one ash's voice by a woman yeah and i guess like with a lot of uh a lot of the yeah the shows that were on like fox kids and jetix and stuff
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy sounds so pissed off to be dubbing a cartoon.
[SPEAKER_03]: Imagine that, like, wasn't TV.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_02]: it's like i think i've seen one where there's a hungarian because hungarian is such a niche like language right and uh i think there's just one hungarian guy who does the dubbing for the entire show yeah so he just puts on like a high-pitched voice for the women and uh it's really really bad i'm sorry but this digimon guy sounds like he's high as fuck yeah just roll up and get them all done in one day
[SPEAKER_03]: Hungarian, if that's the name of the language, it's like really close to Finnish.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is, it's a Proto-Urylic language.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alongside Ignition Estonian, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tell us more, grandpa.
[SPEAKER_02]: How was it like?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, actually, Uralic should mean that it comes from the Ural Mountains, but actually that was just some European guy who thought it maybe came from the Ural Mountains and called it Uralic, and it doesn't actually come from the Urals.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's a fact for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Classic Europeans just naming shit and then, you know, it just sticks even though it's completely wrong.
[SPEAKER_03]: Doesn't Uralic mean like Northern Russia?
[SPEAKER_03]: Eurasia?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's the Ural Mountains it's from.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like that word is from like the Ural Mountains which are in the middle of like Russia.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think it's because something to do with the Huns coming in from the Ural Mountains and some guy decided like, oh yeah, this must be their language.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that must be, we'll call it Uralic because it's not, it's not Indo-European.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think like 40% of Finnish genes are like based on Uralic genes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is Siberia from Ural, like near Ural mountains or?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the Ural mountains are like, yeah, they are Siberia, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the Ural mountains I think are more east, like middle of Russia.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Siberia is like the whole top end of Russia, like top side of Russia right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I think generally people are just annoyed that it's not
[SPEAKER_02]: called something more related to Finland or Estonia, because it doesn't really have anything to do with Russia.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the Ural Mountains being Russian-like.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello, pizza man.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_03]: Remember to change your character from the channel.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wonder if there's not a way to set that as default.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm surprised.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I am trying to have my mic with noise suppression off.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you hear echo of your own voice, or if you hear annoying background sounds, let me know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bye bye.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, I'm done.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is some.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now I can control.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, how did last episode start?
[SPEAKER_02]: I even read the whole, I read the whole novel and everything, I can't remember.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark was at Madame Rook's and then she spent the night at Bellows and then the morning started from Felix and Eska meeting?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah, we went to the... Or was it Felix or Eska, or it was just me and Eska?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, you two met at the Plum and Bob was Billy and yeah, yeah, okay, got it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just can't, yeah, it all kind of matches together to the point where I'm like, I can't remember where the actual episode started and what happened in which day.
[SPEAKER_02]: What does it have?
[SPEAKER_00]: It have some spicy, if the program doesn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: This isn't a lesson, I'm not showing you that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Spicy salami, then onion and this, this, this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jalapenos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jalapenos, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You love jalapenos.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, jalapenos, but those, those, those.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it called kesäkurpitsa?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, kesäkurpitsa.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jukini.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aubergine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aubergine, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why is it so dramatic?
[SPEAKER_03]: Someone's dying.
[SPEAKER_02]: True.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I hope it's not me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's find out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: Should we do introductions?
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody's going to step on Felix and he's going to die.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, introductions.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Maked, change your character.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, let's do introductions.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can begin, Eske.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hi, this is Eske.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hi, I am the humble Biliam.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is Kaldor speaking.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Great.
[SPEAKER_02]: So investigating the assassination of Theodore, you have come together, the five of you,
[SPEAKER_02]: initially at the Plum and Bob and have attempted to locate any kind of clues about why this person who was individually all of your friends or colleague or confidant or whatever he might have been was assassinated and suspicions have pointed you guys towards the guilds
[SPEAKER_02]: in general and perhaps the Guild of Engineers or the Porter's Guild more specifically due to the fact that both of these guilds seem to be interested in Theo and investigating or tracking down either him or you guys for being associated with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Most recently a set of agents from the Porter's Guild came looking for people associated with Theo and you guys managed to escape from them and then
[SPEAKER_02]: investigated why exactly they might be interested, finding out that most likely the items in question that they were looking for was a set of enhanced essence cores that had been part of some sort of scheme by Theo that he was selling on to the Portis Guild in some way.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it seemed like they believed themselves to be owed a debt or owed
[SPEAKER_02]: a delivery or something along those lines, and they were keen to find someone from Theo's outfit, so to speak, who could deliver.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys have not found the cause, but have at least found that Shrapnel was involved alongside a woman called Lucille Fexfield at Fexfield Scrappers, and it seems like Shrapnel has been taken by the Porter's Guild, seemingly related to this event as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But also the Guild of Engineers have been on your tail, at least causing problems initially with the body and also members of House of Elan seem to be closing in on Ask of Elan, the wanted son of a noble family.
[SPEAKER_02]: So many people hunting for the party here, and you guys decided to get ahead of it by chasing down the leads on the Porters Guild at the head of Steam, a tavern out in the core that was often frequented or is often frequented by the Porters Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder took the lead on the dice game and managed to, with some big aura, get a bit of information about these people being connected to an Evan from the Polders Guild, and that came together alongside the information that Asuka was able to gain.
[SPEAKER_02]: by actually finding that the VIP room at the Head of Steam was occupied by an Evan Langford, the son of Sacha Langford, who is headman of the Porters Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: So a powerful figure within the Porters Guild seems to be gathering with these two agents that you also, or Asker at least, met.
[SPEAKER_02]: Asuka met them, but meanwhile there was a surprise to him and a surprise to everyone else, a rat man, a scratcher person who managed to find a way when the need arose to transform his body into that of a scratcher, one of these rat-like constructs, and found his way alongside Asuka into the games room.
[SPEAKER_02]: and Billy who is pinned to the side of the wall peeking around the windowsill to take a look inside the room as all of this happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you definitely uncovered some interesting information, some interesting connections between the Porters Guild here and the various other things that are going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Asuka managed to play a song, impress Evan, who was in the room here, and finish up his one song and basically be invited back for future performances should he wish to continue playing the Head of Steam.
[SPEAKER_02]: with that level up right well you level up when you take a long rest so okay not until that happens but it is later on in the evening now so it shouldn't be too long um so i think we kick off as eska basically like you are shown the door by evan as you finish your performance and he kind of nods and bows to you again and sends you out on your way um however felix you're still inside now billy
[SPEAKER_02]: To what extent, to what risk do you want to take to continue to look inside the room here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because obviously, whilst Felix is basically invisible in this scenario, you are in a little bit more of a precarious position.
[SPEAKER_05]: I probably haven't noticed that Felix is in there.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I've seen enough of the faces that I would just try to listen in and not try to look inside.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I feel like there's no point in unnecessary risk if I can just listen to what they're saying in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so yeah, as Asuka leaves and the door closes, um, you first see that, uh, both of you, um, Billy and, oh no, Billy, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're listening in so you didn't see this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, but Felix does see this as the masked man, this man in a black cloak, porcelain mask, um, stands up and sort of, uh, nods towards Evan as well and says, um, thank you for your time, Evan.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll get back to work.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he walks towards the window where you are, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know this because you're listening in.
[SPEAKER_02]: As he approaches, I would like you to make a stealth check.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Lark, you are also down kind of in the alleyway here, so you may see, make a perception check as well as this happens.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would I see what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we'll find out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you see it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh dear, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy continues his run of roles.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see, Billy, what you don't see until too late, as walking through the wall next to you, the man in the porcelain mask walks literally through the brick wall, through the glass, and sort of floats, like he basically stays on the same level that he was at, but two stories up, as he walks out into the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks left immediately, kind of just checking his surroundings, and you are right there on the wall, standing next to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lark with a 14 you see this because you're keeping an eye out for Billy you can see just like two stories you're at the end of the alleyway you see two stories above you that a man has randomly just kind of walked through the wall and appeared next to Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: What is your reaction Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think out of
[SPEAKER_05]: I noticed that he sees me, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, you guys are both, like, looking at each other.
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, he's not expecting to see you, you're not expecting, obviously, to see anyone walk through the wall next time.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would immediately panic and kind of wish that he would have just not seen me and that he would have fallen down.
[SPEAKER_05]: And in doing so, I would cast Sleep.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: On this mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: On yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: On this mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now you, if I am not incorrect, Billy, have already today used the sorceress ability, which means that this triggers... Rolling a d100.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which might be better than the sleep.
[SPEAKER_05]: I prepared this...
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, I need the 21.
[SPEAKER_03]: What does it mean?
[SPEAKER_05]: 148.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can probably tell me quicker than I can find it, but.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, well, it's for the next minute.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can find it, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: All your spells with a casting time of an action have a casting time of a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, holy shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: I like that you said that.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, did you roll a d8 as well, yeah?
[SPEAKER_02]: I might not do it the same.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: 21, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, not that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, 21.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So for the next minute, all your spells with the Cursing of Reaction have a Cursing of Rebirth section.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, so you're going to cast Sleep on this guy, and he is going to attempt to make a Wisdom saving throw for that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, and I think it's only 12.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me find him.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is such a scary scene.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you can see immediately, Billy, that, well, you can't because he has a porcelain mask and so you can't see his expressions, but even just from his body language, he's as shocked as you are to see someone there when he walks out of the room like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you was, you know, you both kind of have the drop on each other in this in this scenario.
[SPEAKER_02]: He will make his wisdom saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is not particularly wise, I'm afraid.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well, maybe my dice luck is... Never mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: He waves off the spell as you attempt to cast that on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what does the wild surge...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, in this case, there isn't really a visual component to this wild surge happening, but you think your magic is showing in any way as you do this?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think usually when this happens,
[SPEAKER_05]: I think a certain aura of magic surrounds Billion, but it kind of gets pulled back to his arm, where if someone would be looking really good, you'd see that he has a bracelet underneath his clothing, which kind of absorbs a little bit of that explosive magic that would usually
[SPEAKER_05]: Nice, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in this case, I guess the bracelet kind of charges up a little bit and is able to push that magic back into your casting instead of into a potentially more dangerous.
[SPEAKER_02]: Scenario.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He, in response to that, is going to... Let's find out what he can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he is definitely surprised, if nothing else.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gonna Sparta kick you after.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, he I'm afraid doesn't have much beyond damaging magic, so he is going to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: He doesn't have any like utility stuff particularly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Classic.
[SPEAKER_02]: So actually, I am gonna, okay, so you cast a spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is unlikely, but you can make an intimidation check as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: you're positioned like an assassin or an ambusher or something and once the spell didn't work okay um yeah oh how the turntables oh how the turntables he sees him you get a get a do an insight check as well for me
[SPEAKER_02]: can't read much of this guy even with a really good inset check and uh yeah you see him kind of start basically he gets jump scared as he walks out as you're right next to him you try and cast some magic on him which just doesn't work and he obviously feels the the fact that a cast has been made on him but there's another sort of like burst of energy around you and it's clearly you're a spellcaster and you're kind of positioned on the side of the building and with that 20 he is like
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you don't know what he's like, but his reaction is that he immediately sweeps his hand, goes invisible, and you feel the kind of rush of air almost as he moves fast away from you in a direct, like away from the building, fleeing, basically, like as far as you can tell, or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: But initially, he doesn't respond with any
[SPEAKER_02]: attacking magic, preferring instead to flee in this situation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I react now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because I think... Yeah, this is all just like instant almost is this.
[SPEAKER_03]: All this happens like this and this and I see it happen.
[SPEAKER_03]: I sort of lose my air for a second like, holy fucking shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I don't swear or think about swear words, but I rush towards Biliam just below him when he disappears, the masked man disappears and I'm just like,
[SPEAKER_00]: Billy, get down, get down, get down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Billy, get down.
[SPEAKER_02]: So as this happens then, I mean, no particular sound or anything has been made.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think Evan and the people inside don't necessarily notice that this has happened.
[SPEAKER_02]: But either way, this is happening at the same time.
[SPEAKER_02]: With Felix still inside, you're able to see this.
[SPEAKER_02]: once the door closes and once the masked figure has left the room Evan stands up and the agents are still sat at the table he begins to like take his rings of his right hand off and like put them on the table for some reason and then you watch as he puts his hand into his coat and it comes out and he is wearing like silver brass knuckles basically so like you know like brass knuckles but they're made of silver
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and he looks over at the woman sat down and he says, uh, I'm disappointed Gertrude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, and he turns and he punches the ala man straight in the face with the, with the silver knuckles, the ala man's head just like cracks to the side and his nose immediately begins to bleed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, he just seems to kind of take it, but, uh, make an insight check, uh, for me, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to put
[SPEAKER_04]: OK, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll put some battle music on, even though it's not a battle.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it just feels like the slow tension is not appropriate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Within 18, you see this woman who is sat in the green coat, the big woman who is sat there.
[SPEAKER_02]: She darts for a second to almost stop Evan and then holds herself back, restricts herself from stopping him.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he says, yeah, he says, I'm disappointed, Gertrude.
[SPEAKER_02]: says, you fail to get a handle on the situation.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then he punches the guy again, another like blow to the Alamance head and he actually like falls backwards off the chair onto the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says, we're a laughing stock.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he kicks the guy on the ground a little bit as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's right next to you at this point, Felix, like the guy's fallen on the ground next to you and you were like, you know, floor level, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says, we're a laughing stock.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got you and your son into this mess.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he kicks the guy again.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so you're going to fix it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then he sort of like takes the edge of the tablecloth and like wipes the blood off the like silver brass knuckles that he's wearing and slowly takes them off, puts them back inside his coat.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, make a perception check as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you think on the last hit that you saw a bit of a radiant spark explode off the fist, making you know, because this guy is like a nobleman looking kind of he doesn't look like a fighter or particularly strong.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you think there was some magic related to the especially the last punch, he kind of added a little bit of extra the one that knocks the guy off the chair, he seems to have added a little bit of extra kick to it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there was like a radiant spark from his fist as that hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he cleans off his
[SPEAKER_02]: his silver knuckles basically, slips them off, puts them back very carefully and then takes his rings back off the table, puts them all on one by one very slowly as the woman still watches, and he walks over to the door as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: He opens it up and he just turns back and says, don't fail, and closes the door as he leaves as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: As soon as the door closes, the woman sort of stands up and rushes over to where the ailer is like down on the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she begins like trying to like, you know, he's got a split lip.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got like a broken nose.
[SPEAKER_02]: She begins to like kind of dab at his face and that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to do anything, Felix, as this happens?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm just still standing there listening.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to make you make a stealth check.
[SPEAKER_02]: DC is not very high because you are basically like furniture in this scenario but they don't seem to really care that there's a construct in here that's normal enough for them and that's normal enough for that to happen to them.
[SPEAKER_02]: So
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder, you are downstairs, as the only person still in the head of steam at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about Asger?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so I mean, on the floor of the bar, so to speak, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Asger is walking out of the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah I guess actually probably ask what are you doing first you don't know any of this stuff's happened in the room obviously you've just been shown out like are you heading away like what yeah yeah the my first thought would be to gather up everyone and leave because we've learned some pretty valuable information so I would definitely go to Calderford because I know where he is yeah would I yeah because I think that is also my
[SPEAKER_00]: initial reaction once I leave the table, then I would want to be in position where I would see, because I think I heard Aska going into one of the rooms, so I would want to be in position where I see him and then I would want to instantly message him that I got some info.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so you would see him walk out, you know what door he went in, right, you were watching the whole thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you would see him leave the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then at that point, as soon as you get line of sight to him, you can message him as he's coming towards but he's coming down the stairs anyway, so you guys can like meet up in the room sort of and as you're meeting up basically this scene that I just narrated happened.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a cool thing that I made with because me and Lark were doing this earlier.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this one literally came out really good.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's thick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Looks pretty cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys had actually back.
[SPEAKER_02]: here to the head of steam and you guys are able to regroup asker and colder but i think so like timeline wise the masked man encounter the um events that felix is witnessing and you guys meeting up are kind of all happening at the same time so asker and colder you kind of are able to meet up or you can send a message colder or whatever you want to do that
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think I would, as soon as I see Aesca coming out from there, I think I would send a message to Aesca that I was able to get some information that somebody called Evan is responsible for kidnapping and all this mess that is going on over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would want to start to head out of here, out of the pub.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I would reply back with, with Evan.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just met Evan.
[SPEAKER_01]: I recognized him as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I also, I also recognize the two people who were chasing us, you know, the, the, the, the, yeah, the woman at the AILA.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there was another figure, but he had a mask on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I have no idea, but let's, let's gather the rest and get out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We, we, we got some good information.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I guess I would go down.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys are like, you guys have met up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you as you are met up there, the bottom of the stairs kind of at the table that Calder was at or like the temporary place he stopped, not the gambling table, but you see the door open at the top and you see Evan walk out at this point as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he walks down.
[SPEAKER_02]: He seems completely kind of like calm.
[SPEAKER_02]: Walks out like into the crowd and looks like he's gonna head towards the back of the so like towards the doors at the back not out through the front entrance as you decide what to do at that Billy and Lark after this happens immediately with the mass man, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he seems to suddenly disappear.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are your immediate reactions there?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would try to jump down depending on if it's an easy jump and
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, well, you're like two stories up, so you can't jump down, but you can kind of climb and slide your way down.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an athletics check.
[SPEAKER_02]: You might need to catch him to put me on the athletics check.
[SPEAKER_03]: I must be like, he's like climbing down.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm below you, and I'm just putting my hands up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can have advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, luck is going to help you like catch you halfway down kind of.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can make an athletics check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I do acrobatics?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, acrobatics is, yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you were saying about the turntables?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, if Lark wasn't here, I'd beat that again.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um yeah you like within 11 basically it's kind of like a clumsy landing you kind of bump bump down a little bit down a couple of the gantries you fall like lark has to catch you and you both kind of collapse into some like cardboard boxes and shit on the side of the alleyway just like in a pile for a second um and then you guys kind of like dust yourself off push yourself back up and you two are now like in the alleyway um
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, you see Evan leave, you see Gertrude, whose name you've now learned, run over to the Ailer as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you want to do here?
[SPEAKER_02]: just want to stay and keep listening maybe they are still saying something okay yeah so you stay yeah you stay still um pretending basically to be a regular scratcher in the room and listen in on their potential conversation as that happens cool um so yeah i guess colder and ask you guys are leaving well the choice is yours obviously evan is heading towards the back of the pub if you guys are just trying to leave then you can easily get out the front of the pub no problem
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess like I whispered to Calder like, that's Evan.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the guy you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just met him in the room.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: From what I heard, and I was able to gather information, he sounds very scary person, so to say.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I recognize him, but I don't want to share more information than necessary, so let's get out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, let's get the fuck out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys rush out of the front entrance.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy and Lark, are you guys heading also back towards the front?
[SPEAKER_03]: Would I have seen...
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, no, never mind.
[SPEAKER_03]: He wore the mask, so we wouldn't know his emotions.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was just thinking if Lark would have noticed him sort of
[SPEAKER_02]: like being shocked or anything but yeah I think you I think you but like he physically would have like jumped like he would have been you know like like when you walk around the corner and someone's there right next to you that you're not expecting he would have just like jumped back and then immediately like just basically waved his hand which came out from under his cloak
[SPEAKER_02]: and he would have just disappeared.
[SPEAKER_02]: So for you, Lark, he probably looks like a ghost or like a phantom or something, because he's just got a white face, a black cloak, and then he just disappears the second you see him.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's a weird sight for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy's a bit closer, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, now that William's here, I get up with him, I guess.
[SPEAKER_03]: I pull you sort of close to me and I put your hood over your head quickly and I'm like, okay, let's just get out of here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's just get out of here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll talk about this later, okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Agreed.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I have you with me and I hold your arm all the time and I pull you like to the entrance of the bar though so I'm gonna take a peek in because I need to see like Felix or someone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I think you guys will run into Asuka and Calder as this happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you four basically all come out together at the Head of Steams entrance side because you can recognize each other.
[SPEAKER_02]: As this is happening, as you guys are all gathering in the front, Felix, Gertrude is there and she's kind of like dabbing at the blood with a rag and she says,
[SPEAKER_02]: Alistair, I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry about this, son.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, let's get out of here before anything more can happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to sort this out, all right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to sort this out for us.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she kind of like puts her hand under his leg and helps him up.
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a medicine check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he looks surprisingly hurt for a couple of punches, given as well what you know of this guy's like fighting ability in his previous previous scrap that you had with him and how they were able to sort of like overcome shrapnel and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like they had a bit of a scary reputation.
[SPEAKER_02]: He seems very injured for just a couple of punches from a random nobleman.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he seems like woozy on his feet as he gets pulled up into
[SPEAKER_02]: situation but he kind of sort of shakes himself off a little bit, she wipes the blood from his face until he looks a bit more presentable and she kind of takes him towards the door, opens up the door and takes him out as well onto the sort of balcony on the interior and then closes the door behind her which leaves you alone in the room.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then I'm also going to leave
[SPEAKER_02]: shop then back downstairs again yeah you follow up behind and you are on the sort of balcony area you're skittering along the side in like the scratcher um in the like tube for the scratcher on the side of the balcony thing you overhear her as she walks past suzy the um the server that that led ask her up there who was bringing drinks to one of the other groups she goes um
[SPEAKER_02]: oh he's had a few too many don't worry about him because she's like physically holding him and he's like very woozy and injured and she goes yeah don't worry don't worry dear he's just had a few too many yeah yeah and she kind of like helps him down the stairs as you're also following alongside them basically and she begins to take him towards the back entrance as well like so around the corner towards the back entrance of the of the head of steam as well towards these back doors
[SPEAKER_02]: You kind of come down the stairs as a scratcher.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where do you want to go from there, Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm trying to fight the rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an exception check with disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are a very small rat amongst the feet of a crowd of people here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, jeez, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Jesus Christ, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: When they're 21, I think you managed to recognize, like, Asuka's boots, and because you had just been staring at them from the, like, base of the floor, and you see his feet through the kind of forest of other people's legs, walking towards the front exit and leaving the bar as you arrive there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you know that he's leaving out the front.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, then I'm going to walk up to them and then try to scratch his leg or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the four of you exit the Head of Steam, you're standing in kind of like, there's a lot of people outside that kind of classic, like, you know, you get your pint, there's no space to drink.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that people have spilled out onto the street and they're kind of hanging around.
[SPEAKER_02]: furlong is right here next to you guys so it's very busy and there's like a clear delineation between like what is like the safe pavement and then where all these carriages are coming past they don't go fast but there's like they're it's really really busy they're back to back like bumper to bumper if they had bumpers as they move past you so it's basically a physical wall that stops anyone from kind of spilling into that area so people are kind of like stuck up against the sides here but you guys find yourselves kind of
[SPEAKER_02]: having been, you know, having got back together as a four in front of the thing, and then asking you feel a random scratching on your foot.
[SPEAKER_01]: I jumped and I looked down and I'm like, what the heck is this?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I just like kind of like put trying to push it away with my feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: What the heck?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_03]: While this happens, I go, we should leave quick.
[SPEAKER_03]: We should leave.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's Felix?
[SPEAKER_02]: This construct is acting weird, obviously.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like normally these scratches just go from place to place, delivering messages.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sometimes they have small jobs, but they rarely interact with humans unless humans do something to them, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like, guys, there's a scratcher on my feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I do inside check as I look at it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you can also do inside check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I turn as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're looking at the scratcher like what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Inside check everybody.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think even with the 19, with the 15, for you guys, definitely something weird about this construct.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's acting abnormally and not in a way that you would expect.
[SPEAKER_02]: But apart from that,
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think it would even come into your head that it could be Felix, because that's just not something that you know that he can do or really that anyone can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: If only Felix was here, he could talk to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I kneel down to the scratcher and try to see if there's a message inside of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Felix, like, pops open your head and opens up your body to look in the, like, cavity inside the scratches.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's nothing in here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's nothing there.
[SPEAKER_03]: What is this about?
[SPEAKER_03]: Anyway, does anyone know where Felix is?
[SPEAKER_04]: I say yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you say okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I close it back up like, do you know where Felix is?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is he inside?
[SPEAKER_03]: Where is he?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's outside.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I point at myself as a scratcher?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have these like little, I guess, yeah, you could kind of gesture to yourself with the little legs on the front, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, do we have to all do intelligence checks here or something?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that's just up to you guys if you think you understand or not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm like, do you eat?
[SPEAKER_01]: Eska has no idea.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eska has no idea that anyone can transform.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's just like, how the fuck?
[SPEAKER_02]: None of you guys definitely have an idea of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do know that obviously you all know that Felix can speak to constructs.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you know that he has like some kind of affinity with them or has in the past shown to have some like magical association with them.
[SPEAKER_02]: But obviously you don't know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, it's kind of weird to think that somebody could change their form into something smaller than themselves in the first place, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Although I think, Colder, with your 23, there are certainly higher level wizard spells that would do things like
[SPEAKER_02]: like polymorph and stuff like that, that you might have read about that can change.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, it's not like this is breaking the laws of physics.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, you know of like magic that can change someone from something into something else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Transmutation magic is a thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not like impossible.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just weird that Felix can do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's not anything that you know that Felix would do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Normally not into like animals that can
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we don't know Felix yet that well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think in that case, I would be thinking or Calder would be thinking like, wait, so I'm taking the construct and looking and so did somebody polymorph you to this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Somebody use magic?
[SPEAKER_00]: then, yeah, I try to ask all that sort of things like, but I don't understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you four are kind of gathered around and picking up the construct, I think you start to get a few weird looks from people in the local area who, you know, it's kind of the equivalent of like,
[SPEAKER_02]: guess there probably isn't an equivalent but it's kind of like picking up someone else's pet dog right who's like like not with their owner and you just kind of pick up the dog and you're all kind of started looking at it and it's like a bit of a weird situation of like
[SPEAKER_02]: Do these guys, like this scratch came from inside the head of Steam?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like what are these guys doing interfering with whatever it's supposed to be doing, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: As I noticed that, can I just like take Felix with me and I'll just say like, I'll quickly check if Felix is inside and I'll be back here, okay?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because people are looking, so I started bringing the scratcher inside.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I start to walk inside and I'm looking at you like, are you Felix?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's so weird.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe the scratcher is broken.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just check in, Kate, and I'll walk in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm holding you, sort of put you a little bit inside my jacket, and I just peek inside the bar and still try to look through the crowd like if I see you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Meanwhile, I think Calder is yapping to the rest of the group about the polymorph magic, et cetera, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is some spells that people can transform, et cetera, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a 15, I think Felix would have, you think would be relatively easy to spot in this crowd because he's quite differently dressed normally to the majority of the porters guild types of patrons that are here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So a quick scan across the crowd suggests that he's not there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just have the scratcher inside my jacket then and I'll just run back outside to the crowd group.
[SPEAKER_03]: I couldn't find him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe this is really him.
[SPEAKER_03]: We should get going.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sure he finds us later anyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eska says, okay, doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: He would be able to take care of himself if this is not Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's get out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he just ushers to people to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are you leaving to from here?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we decided that the scrapyard is the place we want to meet up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you guys are over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the scrap yard is a decent way across the city from where you guys are.
[SPEAKER_02]: The circular tram is available.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is currently about nine p.m. by the time all of this has gone down.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it is the evening.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the circular tram runs basically on top of the furlong, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And it costs two pennies to ride it as far as you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can ride it in a whole circle if you want, but basically it's just like a two penny ticket to ride as far as you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: That will save you guys like maybe two hour walk.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Take you about 30 minutes on the circular step.
[SPEAKER_03]: Blark still needs to go to Madame Roque tonight, so let's do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can't waste time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: In which case, you guys all have to pay up two pennies to get a ticket.
[SPEAKER_02]: And which are the coppers in your inventories?
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, instead of taking like instead of like a two hour walk across the core to the other side of the city, you guys get there in about 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's only about half nine when you arrive at Claring Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, how long does your Wild Shade last?
[SPEAKER_04]: Hours, half of my druid level.
[SPEAKER_02]: So two hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you still got plenty of time on it as you arrive at Climber's Yard and it's still locked up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, actually, wait, you... Yeah, it locks it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: You locked it up and left.
[SPEAKER_02]: But did you leave, you left the guys inside, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: The other two employees who were with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: They wanted to go in and like search the yard and you said basically don't, but they did it anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you left, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: You left them in there, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And left, if I am correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: I also don't remember exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I don't think it would make sense for him to leave them in there and lock it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, the thing is, if he didn't, he would have had to have hung around until they finished whatever they were doing, which you don't know how long that would have taken.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think you did leave them there because you tried to stop them.
[SPEAKER_02]: They basically said, you're not going to stop us, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going in.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you went fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go in then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know how long they would have been there, so you couldn't have waited for them.
[SPEAKER_00]: They left and called them back like, oh, yeah, just lock the door on the way.
[SPEAKER_00]: At least that was in the story.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you arrive to find that the gate is off the latch, not locked up as you arrive.
[SPEAKER_05]: That makes sense.
[SPEAKER_05]: I should probably go in first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you open up the gate and inside looks normal to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it is still a scrapyard and so it's still kind of as messy as normal and nothing in there kind of looks out of place, particularly, but it just seems like the two guys kind of left it pretty like they just left the door open.
[SPEAKER_02]: They didn't really care about locking up properly.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you enter in and everybody else sort of follows you guys in.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just to give you guys like a better layout of how the scrapyard, I mean, it is quite similar to this picture, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a big yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are buildings on three of the four sides.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can't really even leave out of any of the other entrances unless you climb up on the buildings or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is just this one big gate that kind of, and a wall that basically creates a yard out of this space where there's no building.
[SPEAKER_02]: But there is a then small building that's built which was
[SPEAKER_02]: Shrapnel's office, which is not where Shrapnel lives, but is the office for the scrapyard itself and does the kind of like
[SPEAKER_02]: all the day to day stuff, which you Billy had already gone in and found it smashed up and everything else.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's like a back section, like a private office section of the interior of the office that you hadn't been in before this because shrapnel always kind of kept it locked up.
[SPEAKER_02]: You tried to search in there as well earlier and basically didn't even know what it was supposed to look like, but it was kind of messed up and searched already previously.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys arrive in the scrap yard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you, what do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would quickly look around if Shepard and Steambun are around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think Shepard walks out from around the corner still with his three legs, kind of clumps towards you, kind of off balance.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Steambun, as you look around the kind of area where you left him, is still just on its side, kind of unable to walk.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess I would then kind of wave over the group to say like, well, let's meet in the office then.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sit on the table, whatever.
[SPEAKER_05]: But at least we are kind of inside.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I bring the scratcher on the table as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can do some sort of...
[SPEAKER_02]: It's messed up, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Arcana check or something on him if I recognize that it's magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can do an Arcanography check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Arcanography.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's plus eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: You think, yeah, I mean, you do think that there is some magical effect on this construct of some kind.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, the fact that it's responding to you in an intelligent way is not, you know, that that seems weird in the first place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Constructs don't normally do that or can't.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm thinking definitely polymorphed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm sure that could be, could definitely be an explanation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, you guys are now kind of like safely in the office here.
[SPEAKER_02]: For those of you who haven't been in the office, I guess Asuka and Felix, you can make perception checks here as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty good, pretty good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, this place kind of looks very...
[SPEAKER_02]: disheveled, smashed up, searched through, and it's clear to you, as it was to the others, that somebody was looking for something in particular when they searched through this area.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see a lot of Shrapnel's notes thrown everywhere as well around this area, and you see into the back office from where you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Felix, you're kind of like being held in the middle of everyone, so it's not really like a priority for you, but you can see into the back office that looks also like it's been searched.
[SPEAKER_04]: so um sit sit something's gonna happen yeah what's next i am going onto the ground and then transform back into myself okay
[SPEAKER_02]: Like up to the ground or on the table?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, on the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you kind of wriggle out of Lark's grip, I guess.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've already placed him on the table, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can kind of jump off the table.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, yeah, so the three of you guys all watch, I think, as the scratcher suddenly... Oh, sorry, yeah, four of you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they watch as the scratcher kind of like breaks apart and starts to in a kind of cranking, whirring noise of like,
[SPEAKER_02]: machinery and distress of gears being pulled apart, this kind of noise comes out as the legs extend and become human features, darkened features, and ends up with Felix basically in a fetal position, kind of curled up on the floor where the scratcher was.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, hello.
[SPEAKER_03]: Jesus, that's why you were scratching.
[SPEAKER_03]: I instantly went back to a protective position, like, what the fuck is happening?
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, we brought him all the way here, we're not that surprised, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, but seeing the process...
[SPEAKER_02]: Seeing the process is kind of gruesome and kind of...
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like, what the fuck?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have clothes on, Felix?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, with Wild Shape you do keep your clothes.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like a werewolf transformation kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, all of your gear is actually still on you.
[SPEAKER_03]: How did you do this?
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you hurt?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think I'm okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I have no idea what happened exactly, but... Oh, you look okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Excuse me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, did someone do this to you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, myself.
[SPEAKER_03]: How did that happen?
[SPEAKER_04]: I was trying to think of an option to get some messages from the scratchers and I think too hard and then I became a scratcher.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna kneel down next to you and just like touch your arm and check if you are actually okay, if you're hurt.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just poke him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can make a medicine check log.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think Caldera is taking some notes to the notepad.
[SPEAKER_02]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, as you touch Felix's arm, you get like one of the static electric shocks.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, like if you touch someone or touch something just for like a little quick little burst of static.
[SPEAKER_02]: But otherwise, from what you can tell, he doesn't look injured in any way.
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks perfectly fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's amazing that you can do this.
[SPEAKER_05]: So can you transform like into anything?
[SPEAKER_04]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was the first time that I transformed into something, so... You were in complete control of your actions and thoughts and...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: More notes writing.
[SPEAKER_03]: So...
[SPEAKER_03]: This is very weird and cool and everything, but something really alarming happened with Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I just sort of glanced at Billy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like a man just walked through a wall?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: How did you know?
[SPEAKER_04]: I was also in the drone message.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, what do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: Which man?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah, so I was looking through the window into the room where Evan and the other people were.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, you guys were there too?
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, it was a great performance, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did not notice anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was indeed a pretty good performance.
[SPEAKER_05]: But yeah, this this man with the mask he he walked out through Well, not through the window, but like through the wall like he just Went through it like the wall wasn't there and then he saw me I saw him and I saw that he saw me and he saw that I saw him so I panicked and then I tried to use some magic on him, but
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know what happened.
[SPEAKER_05]: He just disappeared.
[SPEAKER_05]: He wasn't there then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, you say the person mask person going through the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: What sort of mask?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, like a white mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think all of you see Caldera goes completely pale, almost as seen in God and Steve and everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Insight check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I guess we already see what you... Well, I mean, I don't think we need an insight check for this one.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't need an insight check necessarily, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: To see that Caldera obviously reacts to the description of the mask mania.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know that guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's say that is a person that one should stay away very far, far away, if possible.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's dangerous for sure, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So the odds and the color is just a little bit in the panicking mode, probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then asking again, so he saw you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, for a brief moment, but I think he was also panicked and he left immediately.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Kaldor would in that moment go to look at the window.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is anybody outside or something?
[SPEAKER_05]: Make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know Calder, who is he?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you guys see Calder go over to the front window and start looking out paranoid, but then you don't see anything, Calder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think like Eske would immediately follows up with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's like, and he said to Calder, Calder, listen, I saw someone there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I saw, well, I saw three people there that I recognized and one that I didn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: the person I recognize, you also found out information about.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if there's anything you need to tell us about the fourth person who I did not recognize, it's now is the time to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: you'll see Calder locking up that some things are good not to be known and then I just say that then to everyone that it's keep eye on your six and then I say that there is somewhere I need to be and I'm starting to leave I guess.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna catch you instantly.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to jump at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You resist, Calder?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Calder, I'm assuming, yeah, like, is like kind of grabbing your arm or like your shoulder or something, trying to stop you from leaving.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, maybe a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's make a roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure, we can make a roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can do athletics checks here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think since it's acrobatics, like you kind of grab hold of Calder's arm and he kind of like tries to shake it off and you end up kind of like twisting it around a bit so that he ended up like spinning around kind of without him wanting to necessarily and you end up kind of pointing him back towards the room as you kind of stand next to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Calder, you said we can trust you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now is the time that you show that we can trust you.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't just leave us with this information here.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd say you are in more danger if you know, but I'm more afraid that he's...
[SPEAKER_00]: If he saw you guys, then maybe he's already getting more info of our group and I feel like I really...
[SPEAKER_00]: need to go to check my parents that they are fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I will start to move again.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna release your hand when you say that like, okay, are you gonna come back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I go and see and warm them.
[SPEAKER_03]: But, so, I need to give information to Madame Rooke tonight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have anything on the person, the Evan person?
[SPEAKER_00]: And then you see Calder just fumbling over quickly like, oh yeah, I was able to get info from some over the table that
[SPEAKER_00]: person called Evan is is behind all this that he have been kidnapping people he have been I don't remember if I got any reasoning for that probably no I just got the info that he's like yeah connected to uh did we get like information that he was like connected to the essence or anything at all or is it just the kidnapping yeah so I think the gambler that uh Calder was speaking to basically said that
[SPEAKER_02]: Evan's crew was kind of riled up because something had gone wrong and they were looking to rectify whatever the problem was.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then also you asked them, what about if they've taken a friend of mine?
[SPEAKER_02]: And they said, oh, well, if you've taken a friend, it will be at the spire and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they didn't specifically say that Evan had taken anyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: You asked, you started that part of the conversation.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the definite confirmation part you got was that Evan's crew was like annoyed
[SPEAKER_02]: Something wrong desperate they were trying to solve it and that was what was happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, which you know, you can take however you want but yeah, I I tell that and then I'm starting to go to watch the door and as I you know open it then I look back and say that Just be careful of the of the of the white mask person don't say out his name and
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't know his name.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm saying that don't say out his name, but he's called Mr. K.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I start to... Well, before you leave, Aska is going to say, Kaldur, I'm trusting you on this one, but remember that I'm the one with the most to lose here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I trusted you with everything I have, so you better start trusting us or this is not going to go well for any of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'd let him go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Kaldur, you want to immediately make your way to your parents' house?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: As called a heads out, the four of you are left kind of, yeah, slightly shocked, I guess, in the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: Big shock.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess I go to Billy, just like, I'm just gonna come next to you and see how you are, because this is a bit scary.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess like Eska would turn to Felix and ask him like, so what did you hear?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did anything happen after I left?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess, yeah, Felix would tell.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would tell that Evan just hit the ill guy multiple times.
[SPEAKER_01]: And like, I guess everything else, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it seems Evan was very disappointed in the fact that they failed.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well, the only thing I can guess is that they failed in capturing us or anyone with information on Theo.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess Evan must very desperately want to look for more information about the people who are related to Theo then.
[SPEAKER_01]: and I guess like I would say like I remembered Evan vaguely at events I didn't know he had such power you said he took he took two punches and and and what was he what was the other guy's name he he went down immediately he looked pretty tough yeah he was almost completely down so with two punches I didn't know Evan was such a fighter
[SPEAKER_04]: Apparently he is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I guess like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't go alone anymore.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, if you go home, and if that guy that we cannot say his name finds you and your family, like, we have to protect each other, so.
[SPEAKER_03]: Voldemort.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's call him Voldemort from now on.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just came up with this weird name.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's call him Voldemort.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know where to start.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that's the name you're not supposed to say.
[SPEAKER_01]: Different world building.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would call him the masked man, but Voldemort works.
[SPEAKER_05]: The man in the mask.
[SPEAKER_05]: Look, I understand that it could be dangerous, but I feel like if we were already on some kind of targeted in some way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not to this level.
[SPEAKER_05]: We don't know if this guy has any reason to find me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm pretty sure now he does.
[SPEAKER_03]: He saw you outside of the window.
[SPEAKER_05]: But only for a split second.
[SPEAKER_03]: That doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_03]: He saw where you were.
[SPEAKER_03]: He probably is thinking that you were listening in like you were.
[SPEAKER_03]: And before they only thought you were a brat who spit on that guy and they were probably annoyed.
[SPEAKER_03]: But now you are connected to maybe hearing information about them.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will have to meet Madame Rook tonight, but Billy, is it okay if I come to stay at your place tonight?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I just don't feel like you should be alone.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can see Billy, I'm kind of hesitating.
[SPEAKER_05]: But then he agrees.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well, I guess that's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we can, we have a spare bed.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we shouldn't split up so much as a group anymore probably because I feel like things just got more dangerous.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I just, I didn't want to, I didn't want to go inside into the crowded place.
[SPEAKER_05]: Just if
[SPEAKER_05]: something goes wrong like i felt it i felt it today i i tried to use magic and immediately something something takes a hold of me like and like it's not even it's it's like magic coming out of me but it's not mine you know and it's i'm just worried that things will go bad again
[SPEAKER_03]: I saw it, but well, now the only bad thing was that he just saw you, but... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I turned into a scratcher today and I'm fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, trust me, it can get really bad.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I don't want to find out how bad it really can get.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then we have to just make sure we have your back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because you're not the only one who has problems controlling their magic, so...
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm still kind of new to it.
[SPEAKER_04]: A couple of years ago I didn't even have magic.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_05]: Really?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: How... What happened?
[SPEAKER_03]: How did you get that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, how did you get it?
[SPEAKER_04]: About four years ago, my parents took me to a warehouse a bit south of here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they delivered me there with some kind of device that's now inside of me.
[SPEAKER_03]: They put the device inside of you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Why?
[SPEAKER_04]: In place of my heart.
[SPEAKER_04]: Heart?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was just like, why the fuck did I leave?
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gonna say like, this sounds very Guild of Engineers type of shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I like do some checks or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, yeah, you can make an engineering check.
[SPEAKER_03]: And meanwhile, what time is it in the world?
[SPEAKER_03]: So after you guys have talked and stuff, it's probably like 10 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's already so late because we already, we went there like for after four.
[SPEAKER_03]: So is it really that late yet?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: The evening drinking, you, you know, you have to do the dice game and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it didn't take us that long to do those scenes, but it would take you guys a bit of time to listen in travel between places, all that stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think about nine.
[SPEAKER_02]: half nine by the time you arrived here can be a little earlier if you want you're only chatting here in this in the space but um with the 17 doesn't sound like anything you have ever heard of ask it like uh putting machines into people is not done really like you guys know uh an asker specifically kind of knows that like
[SPEAKER_02]: There isn't really any technology that allows you to fuse essence machinery with people, like a biological people, like that kind of thing is way out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: People have prosthetic limbs and stuff, but those prosthetic limbs are always like general mechanical, like people haven't found a way to make like essence powered mechanical limbs and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't see those kinds of things ever.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this would be a first for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: For me, maybe when I was at the College of Arconography, I at least learned a little bit about the basics of magic, where it could come from.
[SPEAKER_05]: Would this be all covered in the basics, or would it also be very niche?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an Arconography check about what you're seeing or what you've
[SPEAKER_02]: been told by Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's similar to, you know, you remember what Calder was saying about sort of polymorphing and stuff like that, that sort of thing, the transformation of objects through the use of magic is not novel or crazy or never heard of.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've definitely heard of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would have read about it at the college as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But certainly, like, you haven't really
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you definitely haven't heard of any kind of like way in which you can, you know, about imbuing people with magic through things like guidance and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again, like giving people like magical buffs and abilities is not crazy either.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's actually like the engineering part suggested that like kind of connecting engineering to a biological person or to a human or something like that is not anything you would have heard of or even sort of have been theorized or anything like that, as far as you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: So why did your parents do that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you know?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think they just wanted to have me show that I had magic then.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys, you guys know about this concept of nomas, which are like no magic people.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, Billy, your mother is a noma.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like completely.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not super rare, but it is relatively rare that people just can't use magic noma.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, filthy muggle.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Voldemort in particular hates them.
[SPEAKER_02]: This whole thing is actually just a Harry Potter clone.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys just haven't worked it out yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Once you get your wands, you'll understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like Nomas are not like super, super rare, but they're definitely uncommon.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's generally, it's somebody that basically, no matter how hard they try, cannot use magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: where they're learning it through the wizardry, the wizard ways, or having the sorceress kind of like inbuilt abilities, like those are the ways people are normally able to use magic, and there are certain just like a small subsection of people that can't do any kind of magic no matter what they try.
[SPEAKER_02]: And those people are called nomas.
[SPEAKER_02]: And maybe there's like a little bit of a stigma at school and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: People might make fun of like a kid in the magic class that can't do the magic, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: But after that point, it's not really like that problematic in your life.
[SPEAKER_02]: It just means you can't obviously do certain jobs and you can't, you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: How old are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just remember all the years.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think it's like 25.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't have it on the wiki, actually.
[SPEAKER_03]: The age.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, we do.
[SPEAKER_02]: or in the coming hours?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, 25.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you in good terms with your parents still?
[SPEAKER_03]: This is a therapy session.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I was first captured for three years when I got the device.
[SPEAKER_03]: What?
[SPEAKER_04]: Theo actually helped me escape.
[SPEAKER_04]: That was about a year ago.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Of course he did.
[SPEAKER_04]: And Theo said that my pens were also gone, missing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that...
[SPEAKER_04]: I haven't seen them for four years now.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is so much.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Could be worse.
[SPEAKER_04]: Could still be captured in that warehouse.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think your magic is awesome.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think you will learn to control it.
[SPEAKER_05]: You did this really cool thing with like a flame blade or something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's actually one of the first things I did when I was in Dozen Magic.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Guys, I have to go to Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_03]: Billion, I'll come to your house tonight.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just knock carefully so I don't wake your mom up if she's already sleeping.
[SPEAKER_03]: And maybe meet here tomorrow?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have so much information to give to her, so I'm gonna do my best.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just make sure to give her the relevant information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just as much as you can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, don't worry.
[SPEAKER_03]: I would rather die than give your information to her.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't you worry, and I start running away from her.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I was just like, let's hope it doesn't come to that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I will sprint as fast as I can to the bathhouse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Before she leaves, Eska just manages to catch her before she leaves like, just be careful.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I give her a bardic inspiration.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I keep my scarf over my head.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I need to use the bathroom.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, quick.
[SPEAKER_02]: That happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: The boy who lived come to die.
[SPEAKER_03]: So much character lore, so much character lore.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wonder if you have told, you probably would have told Calder that you are giving some info to some person.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I briefed everyone when we met like the day before or this day or morning or day.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, and you said that you need to give some info.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think at that point Caldera would also remind you that we don't know on which side she is.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, and I have also said that
[SPEAKER_03]: My Lark said that she thinks that Madam Rook doesn't care about the guild being aside on a guild.
[SPEAKER_03]: She just cares about having as much information and dirt on anyone she can, essentially.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's why she thinks she's sort of object or neutral, but she doesn't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but it also doesn't mean that she's on our side.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, yeah, I think Lark knows that, but she also said that she sort of thinks she can trust her.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what she said.
[SPEAKER_03]: But, you know, Lark's a trusting person.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's about 10 o'clock as like starts to head over, uh, to head towards the bath house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder heads back towards his family home.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, ask Felix and Billy, you guys are left, uh, in the, in the yard here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, are you guys wanting to do anything, go anywhere in particular, do anything?
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, as you three are here, you watch them leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: All three of you can make perception checks for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perception.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why don't you use our passive perception, huh?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I don't really like passive perception.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's just more fun to roll, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the 21, Asuka.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've not really been here before.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're looking around as some people are leaving, as you're having this conversation, you're kind of checking your surroundings out, like, what is this place even like?
[SPEAKER_02]: What is it even for, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: You spot inside the back office of Climbing Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think as you kind of like are just looking around, kind of taking in the surroundings, Felix, you also sort of notice that there is a large hole in the brick wall at the back of the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're muted.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: I said, Billy, you said that you searched this place, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there's a big hole here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as Asuka points that out, Billy, that wasn't there when you were here last time.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's new.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it like, how large is the whole guitar?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like TV, TV screen sized.
[SPEAKER_02]: Big TV or?
[SPEAKER_01]: Cut that.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many inch screens in?
[SPEAKER_01]: How many inch TVs?
[SPEAKER_02]: Somewhere in between one of those portable tiny little TVs and a gigantic 75 inch TV.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's like a cupboard door sort of size.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you look over towards it, it is a square kind of cut out hole in the brick, like it's been cut with tools out of the brick.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can see that there is like a bunch of metal plates on the ground around where this hole was that also wasn't there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're pretty sure, Billy, you would have
[SPEAKER_02]: when you stuck your head in here just to have a look around before, you're pretty sure you wouldn't notice that straight away because it's very obvious.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this supposed to be here?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, that was not there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, wait a second.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I kind of get closer to see if it's leading somewhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you walk over and you see on the side this picture.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is this picture in the back office is not there on the wall anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been put to the side.
[SPEAKER_02]: And behind it, this alcove is cut out.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you see a safe in the behind the picture.
[SPEAKER_02]: Classic, classic safe behind the picture situation.
[SPEAKER_02]: The safe is open and the safe is empty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so I turn back and tell Aska.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I guess there is a safe here, but it's empty and someone must have come here to, well, take whatever was inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who do you think took it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because obviously the Porta Guild guys didn't have it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I mean, I guess Shrepnel, only Shrepnel would have known.
[SPEAKER_05]: So maybe whoever took him has gotten that information out of him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Or they must have had some other way of finding what's in there.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I've never seen this.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think any other guys who work here would have seen it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think Billy, you can make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aske you can make an engineering check.
[SPEAKER_02]: And actually Felix, I think you can also make an engineering check.
[SPEAKER_02]: staring at the safe lying Felix doesn't know much about safes um in this context like i mean you know what the safe is and everything but you don't know about the inner workings or how they how they function and stuff particularly other than you normally dial a code in and open it up sure uh billy you there's no way anyone would know about this surely like
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody tells you, nobody.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who would have thought about putting it behind a painting?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's never heard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aska though, the safe as you go in to look into it has been broken open, not opened with a code.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can see that somebody has spent some time with like a heavy duty, like welding torch to cut through the sides of the door to be able to swing it open.
[SPEAKER_02]: the locking message this must have taken a couple of hours minimum and knowledge of sort of heavy duty machinery and has been and clearly whoever did it obviously didn't have the code right yeah uh so uh this this this was done oh wow like uh you were here this morning right uh billy yeah but i didn't go in here i think
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you were here this morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: You didn't even really go into the scrapyard particularly.
[SPEAKER_02]: You came to check if Shrapnel was here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I mean, I looked into the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And are you sure this wasn't here before?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, it was hidden, if anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, this is a pretty hefty safe and whoever got into it took their time doing it because they clearly didn't have the code.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they must have done it today when we were out and away.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I mean, I guess the door wasn't locked either, but
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I mean, I guess from like 10 in the morning until now, nobody's, well, nobody's really been here except then, I guess, Ursula did this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you said, well, Eska is just very like skeptical.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just looking at Billy like, hmm, are you sure?
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, he will believe him just for the sake of it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do an insight check, bitch.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess I'll do it anyway because like yeah, yeah as guys really wants to know so, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he doesn't know shit So as guys like hmm, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not sure what this guy but you know what?
[SPEAKER_01]: I already fucked up before so I'm just gonna trust him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just gonna not question anything So okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, well, this was this this was done today then yeah
[SPEAKER_05]: And look, I guess the only thing I can think of is, well, Felix, you were there, we talked to the manager from the Facts Field Scrappers and she did say that Shrepnel and her had some
[SPEAKER_05]: business that was out of the books, I think she said.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: So then maybe Shrepnoy had something private hidden in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, wait, I have an idea and Askar just interrupts Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, you can talk to constructs, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we could ask the one construct outside if he saw anything, because he was still, I mean, he's still walking around now.
[SPEAKER_01]: So could you maybe ask him if he saw anything after Billy left?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, then then we do.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we do have to look up soon and I should get home soon.
[SPEAKER_05]: But let's yeah, let's let's ask Steenbund if he saw anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you opened the door to go back and Steenbund is like standing right there by the door, having just followed you towards the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's just like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they're just waiting.
[SPEAKER_02]: What a loyal friend.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'd be Shepard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Steenbund is on this side.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, so yeah, if you yeah, if you have the if you have the spells still feel like so heavy to do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why is [Lark]'s mouth moving?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm singing.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's like maybe she's trying to say something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I ask her.
[SPEAKER_01]: So could you ask him if he's seen anybody entering after Billy left?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'll ask him that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who?
[SPEAKER_02]: One intelligence, remember?
[SPEAKER_02]: Paulus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alfie.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll tell it to the rest.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, can you ask him if
[SPEAKER_05]: He heard any explosions while Alfie and Hollis were here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Were there any explosions?
[SPEAKER_02]: Noise.
[SPEAKER_02]: Noises.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: There were noises?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aska says to Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy, you know this Hollis and... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: They were here this morning.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're my... Well, were my co-workers.
[SPEAKER_05]: They said they were just coming to get some of their stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why did you say no when I asked you if anyone was here?
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you mean, if anyone was here?
[SPEAKER_01]: I asked you if anyone was here today after you left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I did.
[SPEAKER_05]: I honestly don't even...
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't see him hide.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why the whole point of me like... Yeah, that's why I was like, hmm, I don't know... Asker is like, hmm, I don't know if I trust William, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But anyways, yeah, anyways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, now we know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I would have obviously...
[SPEAKER_05]: I would have said like, yeah...
[SPEAKER_02]: I wasn't sure whether you were trying to hide it on purpose or not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, that's what I... Yeah, me too.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I was like, inside check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Inside check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because obviously Aeska knows, because he saw the scene happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Aske doesn't know because he wasn't here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You met those two guys and then they said to you that they were going to go and get stuff from the and you actually said to them, don't go and take anything that's not yours.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they said, we're going to take whatever we want because we're owed wages.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_05]: But that was also what I would tell them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, and that's why I said, well, between 10 and now there was no one because I was there at nine and then there were Alfie Wallace.
[SPEAKER_05]: After that, I assumed they would have just left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but you left before they left.
[SPEAKER_02]: You left before they left.
[SPEAKER_01]: And obviously, Eska doesn't know any of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's why he's asking.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's like, so is anyone else here today?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, that kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: But well, in any case, then we could have saved the Speak with Animals if you told us.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in any case, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I didn't expect them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, anyways, if we rewind back to the part where you actually said it, I think Aska would say, well, I guess we can't really root them out of the culprits here, can we?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they did came here with an intent to take whatever they can.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'm surprised that they found the safe then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because they were not the smartest of our group.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, they saw that everything is ransacked, so I guess they looked deeper than they should have.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, maybe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we can't turn that back now.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, at least we know now that they're bad guys.
[SPEAKER_05]: I never liked them anyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, Alfie was all right, to be honest, but maybe he got dragged in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, listen, we should maybe meet up tomorrow again.
[SPEAKER_05]: I should get to go home and make sure I'm there before Lark is there.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK. Yeah, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And just be careful.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm going to lock up the gate this time.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll open it tomorrow again.
[SPEAKER_01]: And since I'm here anyways, I'll see about fixing your friends again.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to stay here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: For now, we'll stay here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's better if we move around and we don't stay in the same place.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm still going to lock the gate then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not a problem.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I guess I'll just walk out and whisper something to Shepard and close the gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, leaving then just Felix and ask it, um, back here in the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, you guys are planning on staying here tonight?
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, I guess like before Billy and Lisa will ask him like, okay, is there like any place here that we could stay for the night or is it just an office and nothing else?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's just the office.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's at least like rainproof.
[SPEAKER_02]: It wouldn't be a decent place to stay if it wasn't kind of trashed.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could clean it up a bit, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You could make some spaces in the corners.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll make do.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's probably some benches and stuff you can sleep on and some bits and pieces and whatever else.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys start to clear up and start to set it up for the night as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you can both make investigation checks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess like Eska would also want to continue investigating because he doesn't know if they've missed anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you see that this place has been pretty thoroughly ransacked, but there is a lot of paperwork around.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as you start to like kind of like pull everything up and whatever, you do find the employee records that were once kept.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, pretty simple and basic stuff like Shrapnel was clearly not
[SPEAKER_02]: one for doing a lot of paperwork and admin and stuff like that, but enough that you do find these people, this Hollis and Alfie's names and addresses and stuff like that, that are kept by Shepard as well within the files here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everything else is kind of pretty run of the mill and regular and it does look like
[SPEAKER_02]: The problem would be if there was anything extra interesting here, it would have been found by the people that did this in the first place and probably taken away with them or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: So everything else is pretty irrelevant to you guys in terms of your investigating of cause and whatever else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, but you're at least pretty certain having done a thorough check that you're not, you haven't missed anything here, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like it is taken away.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if, if there was anything that's been taken away or maybe there was nothing to find, but, um, you're pretty, you kind of tidy the place up a bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have Felix as you carry the place up and try to fix, uh, whatever his name is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can head over to steam bun.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a, uh, Tinker's tools check.
[SPEAKER_04]: And also try to help with fixing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now we'll cast Mending.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you have Mending.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can start using Mending.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can use the Tinker's Tools.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can roll with advantage on the Tinker's Tools check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dexterity for the skill.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tinker's Tool.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dex.
[SPEAKER_04]: OK, done.
[SPEAKER_05]: Did I get the right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: 14 is not high enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, this thing's pretty damaged and getting it back is like, yeah, again, it's just kind of a situation where you're able to make superficial repairs, but you can't quite get like the.
[SPEAKER_02]: the locomotion of the legs working properly, like you and Felix kind of like pick him up onto his feet as you kind of try and make some fixes and it just kind of takes a step forward and kind of collapses sideways again into a pile.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, unfortunately, the sort of couple of hours you spend doing it is not fruitful.
[SPEAKER_02]: You will have to try again.
[SPEAKER_02]: the future um but you try fucking thing um you do your best uh that you can do but you also kind of clear the place up and so um you guys stay there for the night um as well colder you arrive then having left first at your family home uh which is
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is back in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am right that it's back in the stacks, aren't I?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your family live in the stacks, I'm pretty sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I couldn't quite remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think so as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we can fix it in the lower afterwards if it's wrong.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm pretty sure they wouldn't live anywhere else than the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe the core, but I don't think they do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool, you head back and you make it back to the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think not too far probably will put you on this.
[SPEAKER_02]: cool view of the stacks here, but you're not actually that high up because I don't think they live that high up in the stacks either, somewhere in the middle of the stacks probably.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you arrive back to your family home.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it takes you about, I've actually determined where your parents live exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we'll say it takes you about an hour to get back home once you kind of travel have to climb up through the stacks as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, it gets to about sort of like 11 o'clock at night as you arrive at your family home, you expect your parents will mostly be asleep by this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Calder would be a little bit paranoid still, looking around, seeing, and then I'm looking like, okay, there is no light at my parents' place probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again, I probably would know where the spare key is and then I would go quietly in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can make a perception check and you can make a stealth check.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you don't see anyone around?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, and you're able to kind of let yourself in relatively quietly into the house, which is quiet and dark, your parents being asleep, your old room empty, and then your parents have a room and you have a room.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there's like a kind of kitchen living area, it's quite a similar layout to Billy's
[SPEAKER_02]: house, given that it's also built in sort of the same area.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just basically this big sort of family area with kitchen and there's a dining table which is always covered in like engineering parts and like forge work that your parents bring home, never actually eat on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then these side rooms as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think you hear your dad snoring as you get through.
[SPEAKER_02]: He seems to me like someone who would snore.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is good.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in that case, I assume we or they also have backdoor over there in the house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like most of these, there is like a small alleyway that runs along the side, but generally kept very small and a tight space that has no like roof to it almost.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like kind of like alleyway, very tight and kind of confined alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would want to cast ritual alarm on that door.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it takes like 10 minutes to cast it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but you spend some time and put an alarm on the back door.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think I can only put one alarm, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's... No, I mean, it's not concentration.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you spend the spell slots and the time, you can do as many as you want.
[SPEAKER_00]: But as a ritual, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, nothing here suggests that you can't do, and you can definitely do more than one ritual in a day, for example.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess you can just do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's nothing that permits you from having only one at a time.
[SPEAKER_00]: OK. Well, yeah, in that case, I also want to do that to the front door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you set up an alarm on the back door, set up an alarm on the front door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you doing the audible one or the mental one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mental one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's you do have to be within one mile of the warded area for that to work.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, then I think I would want to sleep on the sofa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably if we have a sofa.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you have a room.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you want to sleep on the sofa?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because I mean, I think I would
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe in the room, but leaving the door open so that I could still hear what is going on in the main area.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I think Calder would go sleep after putting the alarms.
[SPEAKER_00]: A little bit nervously, still thinking about all the things.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know the feeling after watching some horrible horror movie and then you try to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and you're just imagining all the potential masked men fill your dreams as you sleep.
[SPEAKER_01]: For sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Knowing that he can walk through walls, alarms on doors is great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Great.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, actually the alarm is a 20-foot cube.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't have to be a door or window.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can choose a door, a window, or an area that's a 20-foot cube.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you could cover the whole front area as opposed to just the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Colder is clever enough to think about that, because that's Asuka in his dreams telling him to watch out for people walking through walls.
[SPEAKER_02]: It depends whether you think about that in time, in your state.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't read the spell well enough, so I just alarmed the doors.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next time I need to think.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're nervous, you know, you're nervous.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's nervous.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not a commonplace thing that you're doing to alarm your family home, so that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do the doors and you sleep and try and get some rest and we'll see if anything happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, you head home as well back to the same scenario here you're heading back to your family home.
[SPEAKER_02]: And again, it will take you probably close to an hour, given
[SPEAKER_02]: Claring Burns is relatively close to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's probably gonna take you about an hour to walk home.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a route that you do all the time, though, obviously walking to work and stuff normally, so it's not difficult for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so you arrive about 11pm as well, back at your family home.
[SPEAKER_02]: As far as you know, your mother should be asleep at this point as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, how are you approaching that?
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess I'm used to getting home when mom might be sleeping.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I guess I'm not like sneaking, but I'm trying to be somewhat quiet.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I guess my plan would be to see if I can make a place to sleep for Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's like, the sofa's in the family.
[SPEAKER_02]: area, you have like a lounge kind of area similar to Calder's, you have a room and then your parents have a room as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So in your room is like a single bed, I would assume.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your family.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so you, you could make up a bed in your room, or you can make up a bed on like the sofa or
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume you don't want to make it up in your parents' room.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's kind of weird.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, honestly, because Billy is thinking like, his mother doesn't know someone's staying over and he doesn't want her to freak out when suddenly there's a random person on the sofa or anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess he's also not sure if
[SPEAKER_05]: he should would like in the same room like he's like is that she's a girl maybe that's like he's not sure how to yeah yeah so i guess maybe he would try to make just two places like one kind of have an extra place in his room just in case sure yeah yeah that's good that's good
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and the question is, are you going to sleep or are you trying to wake up?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no, we're just going to wait up and anxiously.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like you, it also takes you about an hour to get to, um, I'm sprinting.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are sprinting, um, as fast as you can.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a bit further than Billy's house, so it takes you an hour, but that's pretty fast.
[SPEAKER_03]: At least the bath house was quite near Billy's house, if I remember correctly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's not too bad to get there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you also arrive about 11 p.m. where you see Emery also kind of sat up against the door as he normally does.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is kind of holding the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: And again, he is like more there to sort of let people out than to stop people from getting in.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is him here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he is like sat on his like stool out the front as you arrive.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hi, Emmering.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good evening.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need to get in again.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have things to tell Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm in a hurry.
[SPEAKER_02]: You keep turning up at the weirdest times.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but this time she actually wants to see me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_02]: He kind of looks down his nose and goes,
[SPEAKER_02]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, I'm not bloodied tonight.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm clean.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is an improvement.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you, Emory.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're the best in our run-ups.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you rushed through and it is empty down here, like the baths, and we will not use that later on.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can rush straight up to Madame Mork's room.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I ask though, why is the bath house so empty this time?
[SPEAKER_03]: Shouldn't it be like,
[SPEAKER_03]: Having some customers?
[SPEAKER_02]: You think that by this time anyone who is still here is probably in a room.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rather than using the bath house itself.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the bath house is probably more used during the day by people who are there to like actually get clean and do that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: So now they're getting dirty.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is the implication I suppose.
[SPEAKER_03]: I get up to Madame Rourke's office and I knock.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, yeah, you rush through the rooms and through the corridor up to Madame Rourke's office and knock on the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Madame Rourke, it's me, Lark.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have information.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was wondering, she kind of looks at the clock on the wall, it's like 11pm.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm so sorry, it's been a very long day, as it probably has for you as well, and I'm getting closer to her desk.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh man, so, are you ready?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a lot to tell.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I hope you can keep it relatively short.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would like to retire soon.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is classified information.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I start classified by who?
[SPEAKER_03]: This thing that I'm about to tell you, this is classified.
[SPEAKER_03]: So there's new core technology.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's more powerful than the ordinary ones.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if you know this already, but that is a secret information.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not public yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's something that the Guild of Engineers have already had their hands on.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm quite certain, considering all the things that we have run into.
[SPEAKER_03]: But none of that is public about this.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in relation to that... Before you go on, make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's very good at hiding her emotions.
[SPEAKER_02]: She doesn't show her facial expressions particularly on her face, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can't really tell whether that is new information to her or not, as you continue.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: I sort of expect she knows a bit, some bits already.
[SPEAKER_03]: And both Guild of Engineers and especially Porter's Guild, they are desperate in relation to this core technology.
[SPEAKER_03]: more related to the Theodore's death and the sort of unfinished business that I was talking about that the porters killed is after.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a name.
[SPEAKER_03]: His name is Evan Langford, the son of Sasha Langford.
[SPEAKER_03]: He is
[SPEAKER_03]: He's desperate and angry about some failed or missed deal related to all of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that's why Evan and his crew is on everyone's buttocks currently.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's the thing that's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, make another insight check as you say sort of Evan Langford's name as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're nervously spewing the information, you cannot read her expression at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: And well, related to what we are investigating, there's probably someone held at the Porter's Spire that Evan's crew has captured.
[SPEAKER_03]: And they are being held for disinformation related to these cores and this depth.
[SPEAKER_03]: And well, they're probably not going to let him go, but they're just keeping him there for information, I'm pretty sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: So all of this, can you imagine?
[SPEAKER_03]: Big stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says, I can imagine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, certainly interesting information that you've brought me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, do you understand how this business works?
[SPEAKER_02]: I receive information and I sell that information to a bidder that will benefit from the information to make money.
[SPEAKER_02]: We are the middle people.
[SPEAKER_02]: We are brokers, traders.
[SPEAKER_02]: And for that reason, I do need to take these pieces of information and work out the value of this information.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who could I sell this information to?
[SPEAKER_02]: Who would be interested in knowing this information?
[SPEAKER_02]: And what value does it hold?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't suppose that you know that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not yet, but I am in this investigation and I'm fighting out all sorts of stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think that makes me a valuable person with ears and eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do have ears and eyes.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're pretty good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, it's a lot, and I will admit you've put in a lot of effort on my behalf.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is certainly much more than I had expected you to be able to retrieve in a day, so I will consider your debt paid.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: For this information.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whether it has any intrinsic value beyond
[SPEAKER_02]: The initial interest is yet to be decided.
[SPEAKER_02]: I certainly can't tell the guild of engineers or the porters guild this type of information as it seems like they would not be particularly happy in me knowing it in the first place.
[SPEAKER_03]: But it's a very good dirt to have on someone, this Evan person, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Indeed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Evan is well known, I would say, in certain circles, and I will say that it's not surprising to find him involved in, let's say, extracurricular activities such as these, but the details of such things are always useful and, to the right bidder, potentially valuable.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are many other guilds that would be potentially interested in finding out these types of things, maybe not
[SPEAKER_02]: Evan specifically, or maybe not about Evan specifically, but certainly about these cores that you talk of, new technologies, these sorts of things certainly pique the interest of particular parties looking for any step they can get up on their fellow guilds.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yes, whether or not this information turns out to be incredibly valuable or not,
[SPEAKER_02]: is an aside however I will consider what you've brought me to be sufficient.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you so much madam.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now if you would like to continue in my employ this is an arrangement that we could make
[SPEAKER_02]: But I will say that when I give you a job, I do expect you not to find a way around giving me the information that I want in the future.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sorry about that, but you understand my situation probably from the previous conversation we had.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think it is important that the person you requested information about will stay healthy and alive and without disturbance because he
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, they are probably important to future causes.
[SPEAKER_03]: And keeping him safe means more information in the future as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I will close the book on this mysterious Asuka playing in the corners of certain taverns.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I will warn you that
[SPEAKER_02]: I am but one means of finding information in this city and certainly not the only avenue that people can travel down in order to find out what they wish to know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rumours spread and rumours unfortunately are very difficult to stamp out.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just because I am no longer actively engaged in the search does not mean that other people will not be and I suggest that...
[SPEAKER_02]: You relay that to anyone who might be interested in knowing that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I appreciate you telling me that very much.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am very much interested in staying in your employment, if that is what you meant.
[SPEAKER_03]: Also, I have a suggestion, sort of, which was related to me coming here in this place.
[SPEAKER_03]: in the first place because bathhouse it's a place where a lot of people come in and they
[SPEAKER_03]: talk, conversate and share, you know, information.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right now I'm just trying to find out as much as I can about these events and this would be a good place for me to have ears in.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's why I was suggesting that I could be cleaning and assisting in sort of these boring jobs.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna call them boring now because that doesn't mean anything else.
[SPEAKER_03]: So
[SPEAKER_03]: I just think if I have good eyes and ears in this place, anything I hear here as well, I will bring to you, so it would be a beneficial situation for both of us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Also, third thing, oh no, second thing, I don't know how many things I've said, I'm very strong and I can protect the girls if some creep is being inappropriate, so like that's a plus as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: I care about the girls here a lot, and I think you do as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to use luck.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you do have robotic inspiration if you need it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, I have to roll again.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh my god!
[SPEAKER_03]: Was it 1d4?
[SPEAKER_01]: 1d6, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, look, you are getting a little bit ahead of yourself here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, do not think that we don't already know everything that goes on in the bathhouse ourselves.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is the basis of our business here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we certainly have methods of
[SPEAKER_02]: ensuring the safety of our working staff already in place.
[SPEAKER_02]: However I could see a benefit to having you do some jobs for me to begin with and perhaps if that is successful a more permanent position allowing you access to the bath house and its many clients.
[SPEAKER_02]: But for that I will need a show of
[SPEAKER_02]: trust, so to speak, a show of ability.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have proved that you have the ability to gain information, certainly, but the information is only as useful as it is valuable to the right bidders.
[SPEAKER_02]: So with that in mind, give me some time to
[SPEAKER_02]: potentially see what is available here, and perhaps return to me tomorrow, and I will bring a...
[SPEAKER_02]: If I have anything of interest to me that you might be able to help me with, I will give it to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we will see where it goes from there.
[SPEAKER_03]: That sounds excellent.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will be here tomorrow at some point, hopefully earlier than this time.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am sorry, the day is over.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Really fast.
[SPEAKER_03]: And, well,
[SPEAKER_03]: You already know this, but the last thing is that my situation might go to a point that someone is looking for me and someone might find me here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that's a situation where we have no relation to each other.
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't know me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just a girl maybe being here, working here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you can just give me out, which you, I understand you would surely do anyway.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that is completely fine for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_02]: I appreciate the candour.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, we have a reputation here that often assuages people from doing too thorough of an investigation to the people that work here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so you will be afforded at least a little amount of protection purely by operating within this establishment in the first place.
[SPEAKER_02]: But as you say, should a large
[SPEAKER_02]: wait to be falling upon you, there is little I will be able to do to protect you in that scenario.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is completely okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you for everything you have been giving me so far, so I appreciate it and I will be here tomorrow and if there's anything else, let me know and I hope you have an amazing night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will certainly try.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she kind of nods at you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll leave and I'll get my stuff from Nell's room because they're still there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you head down, make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you head over to the room of Nell and open it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's not inside.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I'll just get my stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'll head out and while I head out, I'll ask Emmeryn on the door.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that like
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's Nel?
[SPEAKER_02]: She's not here.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says she should be inside.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, like where?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just check again before I leave and I'll just I'll go back in and just circle around the place a little bit at the baths and everything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I see her?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think make a perception check, maybe.
[SPEAKER_03]: Crimson, if you do anything to this NPC, I will fly to United.
[SPEAKER_03]: Perception, did you say?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Dean.
[SPEAKER_02]: You rush back, kind of looking around.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bottom floor is still empty here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You rush up to the second floor, kind of open her door.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's not in her room.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then you hear her voice coming from one of the private rooms on the opposite side of the hall.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, good.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not going to listen in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just wanted to hear her voice and I'm going to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: You rush out and head to Billy's house.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you arrive probably 20-30 minutes after Billy has arrived.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Billy, you are waiting 20-30 minutes before you arrive.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you want to approach Billy's house once you get there?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have my scarf above me and I'm also not paranoid, but I'm just careful and looking around that nobody's following me as I go to the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a perception check if you wish to be very paranoid.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who knows?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're still, you're feeling exhausted.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, you've had the whole day's worth of exhaustion.
[SPEAKER_05]: um messing with you so but as far as you know yeah and i knocked on the door a couple times carefully yeah you hear that billy i think you're you're listening out for it so yeah i'm kind of waiting a second to hear if i hear my mother wake up or anything but i will quickly head towards the door and let her in yeah i don't think you hear your mother stirring as a result
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it like dark in your house now or?
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess there'd be a little bit of light, like candle light.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, up to you, really.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, yeah, your mother wouldn't have left any kind of lamps or lights on, obviously, but when you got there, you could turn something on, like a candle, whatever, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'd probably have something.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK. Hi, Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thanks for letting me in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have all my stuff now.
[SPEAKER_03]: It went really well, but I just didn't want to push it and stay there.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I already said I'm going to come here and I didn't even ask, but thank you for letting me stay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is your mom sleeping?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I think so.
[SPEAKER_05]: I didn't check if, but she's either sleeping or she's not home.
[SPEAKER_05]: So it should be fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, thanks.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where do I sleep?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I wasn't quite sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: I made a bed in my room.
[SPEAKER_05]: But if you don't like that, I made a place for you to sleep on the sofa, if that's better.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just sent my mother to know.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just come to your room.
[SPEAKER_03]: We could talk.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. Yo, shut up.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I bring my stuff and I see the band you made.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, wow, this is so nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thanks.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I just grabbed some stuff.
[SPEAKER_05]: I hope it's not bad or anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, this is amazing.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've used very bad stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is luxury.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I put my stuff down.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: So do you...
[SPEAKER_03]: So since Scrap... Shrapnel?
[SPEAKER_03]: Shrapnel?
[SPEAKER_03]: Shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_03]: Shrapnel is not the... Did you tell... Do you have work tomorrow?
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you get a job with Felix?
[SPEAKER_05]: I didn't get a job, but Felix did.
[SPEAKER_03]: So maybe tomorrow both of us can head to the scrapyard already.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where did Mr. Eska and Mr. Felix go then?
[SPEAKER_05]: They are still at the scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_05]: What?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think they're gonna sleep there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's surprising.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're both like fancy pants.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess, yeah, but they're still homeless, so I guess it's better than nothing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It just sounded like such a dig.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, they're both fancy pants.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but they're homeless.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not like me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not like me with a home.
[SPEAKER_01]: I still have a mother and a father.
[SPEAKER_03]: My dad has something in mind I forgot.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, the guy, the masked guy, are you scared?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm also getting ready for bed at the same time.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's definitely a bit scary what he did.
[SPEAKER_05]: He walked through the wall and then he disappeared.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know if it's some kind of magic, but he did it with such ease that
[SPEAKER_05]: if anything he's quite a strong magic user so i hope he's not like really evil like i'm hoping that maybe he's just a mercenary of some sorts because he did i did overhear him say that to to evan he said well i gotta get back to work so
[SPEAKER_05]: He does work for Evan in some way or form, but we don't know if he's really in allegiance with him or just doing a job.
[SPEAKER_03]: But Calder said that he's very dangerous and we shouldn't even say his name.
[SPEAKER_03]: And did you see how pale Calder got and he just ran away?
[SPEAKER_03]: He didn't look that scared when he was fighting two holes and a guy with a gun.
[SPEAKER_03]: And now he looked completely scared.
[SPEAKER_03]: And he didn't tell much, so I'm really worried.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, maybe something happened with him and the masked man.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we have to dig that information out of him because he needs to start trusting us if we have to do this together.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, definitely.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, I've never done anything like this before, like have a big group like this trying to solve something together.
[SPEAKER_03]: Even though this is so dangerous, I think this is pretty cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_05]: I...
[SPEAKER_05]: It's cool, but...
[SPEAKER_05]: I also wouldn't mind just going back to normal.
[SPEAKER_03]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like you just want to get back to work and forget all of this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, at least when I went to work, I kind of knew what I was doing.
[SPEAKER_05]: And now I'm just always kind of lost, you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: But if you just got back to work and you're feeling like this, then you would never learn to use your
[SPEAKER_03]: magic or like we have the courage to do it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then you would just go back to your boring job and never, you know, improve yourself.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not that boring.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I just mean that you don't want to use magic, but you have such great magic you probably could use.
[SPEAKER_03]: So it should be, we should, we should help you with that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, but I don't know if I can.
[SPEAKER_05]: I tried, but it just doesn't
[SPEAKER_05]: work very well for me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Even if I went to the College of Archonographers and I was supposed to study there, but they all like, they read the spells and they get their stuff and then they can learn spells, but I've never been able to do that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just don't understand how that works.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, then it just works differently for you.
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't have to be like them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I guess, but... Billy, you need to have more courage.
[SPEAKER_03]: You already did a brave thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: You walked on the wall there and you spied into the rooms and you used magic even though it didn't work as you intended it.
[SPEAKER_03]: You still did a brave thing and that's improvement.
[SPEAKER_03]: You have to keep trying.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we're gonna be here for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll still only use it if I really have to, but... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess...
[SPEAKER_05]: I can try a bit more.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll be there for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, should we go to sleep, do you think?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, probably.
[SPEAKER_05]: You look quite tired.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm pretty tired.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it okay if we sleep a little bit later than normal tomorrow?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I feel like I have some sleep to catch up.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we should wait until my mother leaves anyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: So.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you don't she has she wants me here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, well, it's not that I think last time she already, like made a bet for people when when I said they were staying over.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I think it's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's just that this time, some things are different.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, I'll, let's just, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can.
[SPEAKER_05]: Also, if something, if it does happen that you see her, maybe just pretend like you also work at the scrapyard now.
[SPEAKER_05]: She doesn't know that the scrapyard is not
[SPEAKER_05]: not uh working okay yeah okay and my father probably thinks that i'm gonna turn myself in so i hope i don't see him soon so then i have a lot of explaining to do yeah what's up with that well let's not talk about that now let maybe some other time but yeah you shouldn't do that anyway let's try to sleep
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good night, I guess.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good night.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Kolder, as you sleep, you suddenly hear nothing at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you guys can take a long rest and Asuka you can level up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: How do Asuka and Felix sleep?
[SPEAKER_03]: Are they like comfortable?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's comfortable enough because it's a private area with a roof and like some benches and stuff that you can sleep on.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not, and it's not literally sleeping on the streets.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can still take, you don't take exhaustion or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, level up, level up.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a level up button.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is a level up button.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Finally.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you actually get a good night's sleep because you're in someone's house.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, so it rolls the hit point automatically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can then go into it and edit it and roll it yourself if you want, or you can take the...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's one die, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's only one hit dice that it rolls.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It does roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the same as rolling.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just if you wanted to do it yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get an additional cantrip.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get a level two spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, what is all this like features one, two, and three?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, wait, those are the things you get with the levels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And ability score improvement.
[SPEAKER_01]: So.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And you can also instead dig a feet there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have four feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me have a look.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you plan to include your level up to the story?
[SPEAKER_02]: It depends what you get for leveling up and how that might work.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think level four for me is not that interesting because I just get an ability improvement and then I get a spell level.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get a spell slot and a cantrip slot, but that's it.
[SPEAKER_02]: uh no i'm just gonna improve my thingy go back uh no i want to oh yeah so as you're doing that um the fourth of tide finishes uh the night rolls over to the fifth of tide looms day is complete and we move to uh
[SPEAKER_02]: Valde, which is named after the god of evil and bad things.
[SPEAKER_02]: The middle of the week, the hump day, is named after the evil.
[SPEAKER_02]: So whether there is an omen there or not, who knows.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you guys all wake up in your various places.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, I mean, you can you guys can let me know where you want to head immediately and what you want to do.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are we going to work?
[SPEAKER_04]: Ah yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Makes sense.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yes, it is.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not jobless anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so Felix can head straight to Fexfield Scrappers from Climbing Bones for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anybody else?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, anybody else got any specifics where you're going this morning or where you're headed?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would try to get some breakfast for us, assuming there's nobody home.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so when you wake, yeah, if you're sleeping in late, then you would wake up after your mother has already left.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think she would usually leave some like, food on the on the stove for you kind of thing, like, but just enough for one person.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have to kind of like, add something to it to make it into a two person meal.
[SPEAKER_02]: But but the house is is empty as your mother's gone to work and sort of is assuming that you're going to work
[SPEAKER_02]: even though you actually sleep in longer than you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I would, if Lark agrees, just kind of slowly head towards the scrap yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Scrap yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Clarence, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, Calder, you wake up in your parents' house.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you wake up and your parents have not yet left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, by the time, like when you wake up at the normal sort of time, uh, so do you want to sort of, they don't know you're sleeping there right, right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: So do you want to, uh, sort of approach them or are you kind of like trying to hide out or what?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would want to warm them.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, so I, I, yeah, I think I would make them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you kind of come out of your room and.
[SPEAKER_02]: Johan and Vanessa are here and they look shocked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, you walk out of your room.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't expect anyone to be here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And your mother goes, oh, Colder, what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: I came late yesterday evening and you guys were already asleep.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I didn't want to wake you up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I used the spare key.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll put some more food on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bacon, eggs, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: And when I and then Calder sits to the table and says to both of them that
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe for your safety, I don't want to share too much info, but we are learning new things on this investigation.
[SPEAKER_00]: While I'm still safe, one of my party members was seen by a bad person.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean a bad person, Koldo?
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean a bad person?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's difficult to explain and I promised to explain it once all his things are sorted out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your father says, you meet someone from the college?
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you made an enemy?
[SPEAKER_02]: A rival perhaps?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's related to the Chaos Destiny.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's different sort of bad persons.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I did not see them.
[SPEAKER_02]: You really shouldn't be getting involved with any kind of bad people.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, that's why you're at the college to further your studies, not to be getting involved in any of these kind of escapades.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know, I know, I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm still doing all the work.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just letting you sort of know that if anybody is coming over here to
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ask info or acting oddly that you don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just be careful, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your father picks up a big wrench from the side that was leaning against the side of the table and he's like, oh, I'll give them a wallop if they turn up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't you worry, Calder, don't you worry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, maybe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, just be careful.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will be.
[SPEAKER_00]: Also, like I said, nothing has happened to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just my... Well, you really shouldn't be hanging around with the types of people that are getting you into trouble like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, then culture is somehow a little bit, you know, just difficult.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's about trying to eat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But of course, if you say be careful, we'll be careful.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I'd really rather you didn't bring any of these kind of things home with you, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me too, me too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and so you sort of want to eat some breakfast with your parents, uh, warn them of potential something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and then I would leave to the scrapyard as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you had to back to the scrap yard as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the four of you guys arrived back at the scrap yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, you arrive at, uh, Fexfield Scrappers, uh, where Lucille and, um, well, her, uh, person who was indicated to you as her brother, although you didn't actually get the name of him, um, opens the door up to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he goes, are you all right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, fair, fair.
[SPEAKER_02]: What you doing here?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm here for work.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, is it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whoa.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lucy didn't say anything to me about that.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, you better go in.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you kind of like less you through.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm Hugh, by the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I'm Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: He holds out like his huge hand.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm shake.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll shake his hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hugh with huge hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's his picture.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's this really big scrapyard kind of foreman.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hugh Chan comes out to kind of greet you and he goes, yeah, the seal's upstairs, just head on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll go there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she greets you and kind of lets you in and says, hi Felix, you all right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Look,
[SPEAKER_02]: I was thinking about what I could get you to do when you're here, because you said you've got some pretty good, you've got a nose or two for admin, right, for doing books and numbers and that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, that's correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I'll be honest with you, we got a whole load of stuff that we haven't really been dealing with.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's a lot of work, but if you're all right with it, I can do with you to kind of like sort all this out and kind of get an idea of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll start with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she like opens up like a cupboard and it's just like stacked with those like binder folders of just stuff, but none of it is like properly labeled.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's just like random stuff that's like, you know, all over the place.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she's like, off you go.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you start to kind of like, oh shit, kind of work at it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the question is really whether you are trying to do any more than just
[SPEAKER_02]: that today?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, are you kind of trying to push your luck, let's say, to investigate a bit deeper into some of the stuff that she probably doesn't want you to see?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think I'll currently just do the books that she's sending me and also just reading those books for now.
[SPEAKER_04]: To get an understanding.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just not anything extra at the moment.
[SPEAKER_04]: Trying to get on a better side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So make an intelligence check and also make a persuasion check for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just a straight intelligence and then persuasion.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yikes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Doom doom.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, this guy is as smart as a hunter do so.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, perception.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, persuasion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you definitely get on with Lucille throughout the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: She only needs you to work mornings, basically doing the books, like it's not a full time position.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not needed to really to have someone like full time just sitting doing accounts.
[SPEAKER_02]: But so for the for the morning, she has you work and everything you get on well with her.
[SPEAKER_02]: But
[SPEAKER_02]: you don't really make a lot of progress when it comes to kind of trying to work your way through all of this like filing and admin and shit like you end up kind of having it all just like spread out across the desk and like trying to even just work out which parts go in which place and whatever but but at the end of the morning anyway you at least i mean you're able to make it look like you've been making some progress and doing stuff even if you haven't really made like any
[SPEAKER_02]: major breakthroughs or anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and so, uh, as the morning concludes, she's happy enough with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, something I forgot to say is that you guys should all, you guys all need to pay up for your previous day, your looms day, um, costs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, so you guys have free accommodation, Asker and Felix, uh, Billy and all of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: All five of you have free accommodations.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't have to pay anything extra, but you do have to pay your sort of like,
[SPEAKER_02]: normal day-to-day like lifestyle costs.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's written in your player brief to find that because it's different for each of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now I will say that if you choose you can kind of change your lifestyle costs.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're related to like in the wiki as well lifestyle expenses specifically.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can just put that
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll put the link in general.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys have chose based on your character backgrounds and we discussed it a little bit in your one-on-ones and stuff, but you can drop down or even increase if you think that it makes sense for the situation and you wish to either spend less or spend more on your lifestyle costs, given that now some of your...
[SPEAKER_03]: I've done it by day, like what I do in the day, if I know if I'm spending for eating or if I'm spending it for sleeping as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this doesn't include accommodation.
[SPEAKER_02]: So accommodation, we calculate depending on where you guys end up sleeping for the night, because I mean, like for last night, all of you guys, it was free.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, this is just for all the additional stuff that you might need during the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so yeah, you guys have one that we set up in your sheets.
[SPEAKER_02]: But like I said, if you think that it makes sense to kind of drop down or something, because of a change of situation in the game, then you can sort of decide that yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: But either way you do have to pay up all of you at the end of the day But Felix you get paid you make two marks a day for your part-time job
[SPEAKER_02]: So she will pay you for your half a day's work, pays two marks up to you and sometime around noon you are then sort of free as well to continue.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rest of the four of you meet back up at the scrapyard in the morning as Felix is over working at Fixfield Scrappers.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys all come together to find Asuka kind of still at the junkyard.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess, Felix, you've probably had to have like climbed over the gate because Billy hasn't turned up to actually unlock it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you realize, you know, if you get to work on time, you've had to like climb over the gate, but it's relatively easy to do so.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do that, and then Billy, you arrive to unlock the gate, and then Lark, with Lark, and then Calder also arrives at roughly the same time.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys group up together then back at Claring Bones, whilst Felix is at work.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's the morning.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right away.
[SPEAKER_03]: Calder, were your parents OK?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: How are you looking?
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you still looking very nervous?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think not so nervous but still uncomfortable.
[SPEAKER_00]: So looking over the shoulders a little bit etc.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just sort of looking at everyone like holding my hands like, mm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, do you care to give us more information on what's happening?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are you still on that level where you don't want to say that yet?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, he's a dangerous man, not necessary by himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know that, but he's dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Informative wise, he knows a lot of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: And well, I think he easily get to know things by other people.
[SPEAKER_01]: He seems to know quite a lot about this man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was he someone that you previously had encounters with, worked with, whatever?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think you see Calder kicking something on the ground.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well, I guess we're still on the stage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Listen, I needed some money.
[SPEAKER_00]: Institute or college was not...
[SPEAKER_00]: cheap so say i had to get some information to him yeah so he he have he have he have ways to get information well i guess it's better than uh than nothing but uh yeah
[SPEAKER_03]: I draw inside tech.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, we're, we're probably over the face of not trusting each other right now, but are you away for now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe I can, I can, I can, I can say the chop.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you, so you are, you're a Volan, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you haven't realized that by now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think there was some sort of fire in Volan's building a couple years ago.
[SPEAKER_02]: This would have been after you were kicked out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ask him, you probably heard about the fact that there was a fire at your home, family home.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I've heard.
[SPEAKER_01]: What about it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it was related to the event that when I had to get information, you know, and then, I don't know, some things over there went crazy and the building seems to be on fire or inside interior seems to be fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: The, you know, the clothing from out to the window were
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if I take this correctly, you gathered information from my family.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that what you're saying?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't know back then that it was your family or I didn't know who that was, but it was the target.
[SPEAKER_00]: that I got to be paid for.
[SPEAKER_00]: And now I have learned that your father is working with Benjamin and then people are taken by Eavan and then this masked guy is also involved so it's interesting that the masked guy wanted some information from your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: What kind of information do you want?
[SPEAKER_00]: He wanted to know some information of some objects, some pouch, but that is all... You don't ask, you know, the person is the type of person that you don't ask too many questions.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he just told you, you have to get a pouch.
[SPEAKER_01]: That sounds like not a very...
[SPEAKER_01]: Good explanation.
[SPEAKER_01]: He couldn't have just said to you, get me a pouch.
[SPEAKER_01]: What kind of pouch is it?
[SPEAKER_01]: What is in that pouch?
[SPEAKER_01]: What did you need to get?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I know more equally to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Purple pouch.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can make an inside check.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe you, but it's just like...
[SPEAKER_00]: But listen, if you... And I hope that you won't meet that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I hope nobody of us meet that guy again.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the sort of person that you don't... ...sense from.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because, like I said, I needed money.
[SPEAKER_00]: I met him that time.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got that task and he already knew my parents.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he threatened you to get information?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: He didn't never say anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: He just asked how my parents are.
[SPEAKER_00]: By the name so it was it was a little and by the schedule so it was a little bit odd so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's say.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's hope we nobody of us meet that person.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think I would have any idea, but he's talking about with like a pouch and the house fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I think make a.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make like a, you can make a history, like a politics check, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that, I mean, purple is your, is your house's, your family color.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it being purple is kind of like logical.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the pouch suggests to you that
[SPEAKER_02]: You know that your family is in possession of a number of magical objects artifacts and things like that that you've not really ever been like given but like for example like your father might have a ring that has like shield built into it or something like these kind of like relatively common but very expensive types of things that you might have
[SPEAKER_02]: And often they might be kept in things like velvet pouches.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the initial suggestion to you is like some kind of magical object or something that would be kind of more precious than just like jewelry, where you would just keep that in a jewelry box or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's probably something more magically linked to your family in some way, but it doesn't ring a specific bell to you about something that you would know your family having.
[SPEAKER_00]: The point being is that it's so weird that he wanted some information from your father apparently or your family.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if, yeah, your family.
[SPEAKER_00]: And now they are working, maybe related together.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he was definitely there at the
[SPEAKER_01]: at the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he definitely must be involved in some way.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess we can only find out.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have to find out that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, before he finds out us.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm looking at William while.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: He says come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyways, Eska would then look at Lark and say, well, Lark, you're still here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's good, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess you were able to convince Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_03]: It went well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now she has all the information that we have as well, which I don't know if it's a good thing or a bad thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, she doesn't know about you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, she sort of gets the context clues about Mr. Eska, you, that I know you, but that's all she knows about us.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, I am managing to get a job from her today, most likely, with like, I need to gather information for her and maybe we can benefit from her then as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or I don't know what kind of benefits there will still be, but I just think that it would be useful to have Madame Rourke on good terms with us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, yes, definitely useful.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but I mean, I think we still need to remember that we don't know on which side they are.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't even know what lights there are, Calder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's how it could be.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, what did you say?
[SPEAKER_03]: like how many sides there are.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if there's this side and that side.
[SPEAKER_03]: There can be many sides.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's only one on our side, you know, and there are multiple other sides.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think what Carlos is trying to say here is that...
[SPEAKER_01]: You shouldn't trust Madame Rook too much.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've been together for a while now, and you do tend to be a bit too trusting.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's not a bad thing, but... What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't know if I trust you guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if you don't trust us, I don't think you would have been here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would still come back here every time.
[SPEAKER_05]: But you're here, Aska, so we could say the same thing about you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_05]: Although you don't strike me as a trusting type, to be fair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I do have to say that I have improved from where I started.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if I may say so, you guys probably understand why I was very untrusting.
[SPEAKER_01]: to mostly anybody, basically.
[SPEAKER_05]: Not particularly, but I can forgive it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you seem to be the untrusting to have yourself, William.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I would hope that you would understand.
[SPEAKER_05]: Me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Me?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know which meme?
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the Spider-Man meme where all of us are pointing at each other like, you're untrusting.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you're untrusting.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But let's just say that in the situation we're in, there has to be some trust involved.
[SPEAKER_03]: We just have to get to know each other better.
[SPEAKER_03]: And for that, we have to be open with each other.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right, Calder?
[SPEAKER_00]: Meat?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: And trust me, I say all the relevant information.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't hide information that could put us in danger.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because now that they have seen one of our faces, I'm afraid that it can spread, so to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you're scared for yourself?
[SPEAKER_00]: Also for myself, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And for you guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: And for my parents.
[SPEAKER_03]: Insight check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you scared for us?
[SPEAKER_00]: What is the one that if one is saying truth, it's the persuasion is if you're trying to persuade them, you're telling the truth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I mean, basically, Calder is very persuasive about this.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's as far as you're concerned, telling the truth.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright then.
Well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm trying to say is just be careful with Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody of her position doesn't do anything for free.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, that is very true.
[SPEAKER_03]: She has made that point very clear.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I am, I can assure you, I will not give out information about you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: So it's just basically my head on the table.
[SPEAKER_03]: So don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we should probably talk about our next steps.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess we have to move a bit carefully, but I also feel like we had a pretty successful day yesterday.
[SPEAKER_05]: Got a lot of new information, so I think we're doing good.
[SPEAKER_03]: I actually have one idea I can do today.
[SPEAKER_03]: I could go talk to Mira in the brass line and ask about Evan.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know she doesn't care about the guildies that much and wants to stay out of the politics mostly, but maybe she knows the name and maybe she can tell anything that's relevant to Evan.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, I could go do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And after that, I can go to back to Madam Rook to hear what she has for me, because she was planning.
[SPEAKER_03]: She was planning to test me today.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I'm just going to go hear what that's about.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, as you four are discussing, uh, this, I mean, you guys wanting to head out straight away to do stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you waiting for Felix to come back from his shift?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think waiting.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so Felix, I think you arrived back, uh, at the, you guys have just spent the morning kind of discussing stuff, deciding what to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can still obviously continue to do that, um, as well, but Felix, uh, returns back, um, as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Felix make me a perception check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah I mean nothing seems seems off to you you head back to to the scrapyard open up the door head inside and head towards where the office is where everybody else is talking I think it's a normal work day in the middle of the day so there are carts going past and people and nobody is looking
[SPEAKER_02]: particularly at you as you kind of enter a scrapyard in the middle of the day, it's not an odd occurrence.
[SPEAKER_02]: You meet up with the, so all five of you are now in the office here meeting up in the scrapyard as you chat.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what's the plan?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, obviously you can continue to discuss, but if anyone's wanting to go and do something today, you guys are now all sort of together and can kind of decide what you want to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we brief Felix about what we talked about.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I can think of a lot of things to do, but I don't know which one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, same.
[SPEAKER_05]: Priority.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, what do you get thinking of?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I'm like, I have one thing.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, it kind of depends how
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I feel like, one, I'm a little bit resentful towards Hollis and Alfie.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why they would steal from their boss, basically.
[SPEAKER_05]: So that would be something I would want to confront them about.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would also...
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess you guys explained that to Lach and Cold who weren't here when you guys found the safe and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys can see the safe because you were in the same room and all that.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the safe was open, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it was empty.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's been like busted open, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And that could help of course with finding out if they did that for themselves or if they had some other information or help.
[SPEAKER_01]: And maybe what they took, that would also be pretty helpful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because it could be money or it could be something else.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: By the way, it could help Shrapnel, maybe.
[SPEAKER_05]: If he's still out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess what... And then we have the name Evan.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can go...
[SPEAKER_00]: I was going to say like, I...
[SPEAKER_01]: I was thinking like, maybe ask her what else I could do is go back to the bar or names that that place had esteem had esteem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, uh, he would like, uh, because, you know, he's, he's welcome back there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's going to go there, chat the barman and then try to get a bit more information on, on Evan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seeing as Evan is obviously a regular customer there.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's something Aska would want to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and then I think Calder would, you know, as you guys still don't trust Calder very much.
[SPEAKER_00]: So then as a sign of being trustful, I think Calder would say that I had some connection from the gig so that I could have some extra info.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just need to go get it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are discussing different plans of action, et cetera, and the bell rings on the front gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, this is the bell that people ring when there's like a delivery coming into the scrap yard or some, you know, it's just like the bring an employee to the gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ring, ding, ding, ding, ding.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, guys, stay here for a second.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll see what's going on.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I don't know if we have a light on or not, but I would probably.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's the middle of the day, so.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, so it's bright enough.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I would close the door to the office if that's still possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not lockable because it's been broken into.
[SPEAKER_02]: It wasn't destroyed, it was just broken into.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then I'll head towards the gate and figure out who the F is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you open up the gate and on the other side you see a
[SPEAKER_02]: A kind of older human man who looks like he's in overalls, kind of leathers, and he's got a big cart behind him, which has a big crate on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's being driven by a younger kind of ailer guy who has like dust cloth kind of covering his face on the seat of the cart.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he and the older man says to you, Claring Bones, is it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, this is Claring Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, got a delivery for you, mate.
[SPEAKER_05]: Delivery from who?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just deliver him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, and who's that with you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's the driver.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: But why is he all covered up?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you ever been on the furlong, mate?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like a dust city out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'd be covered up too if you were driving a car all day.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, can he show his face for a second?
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a persuasion check, I guess.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I think.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, take it off, it goes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah, I suppose.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oi, mask down.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the guy pulls his mask down.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's like a younger, ailer guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make an insight check, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: With an 11, nothing stands out to you about him in particular.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I don't recognize him at first glance.
[SPEAKER_05]: You don't recognize him, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's one thing I should ask.
[SPEAKER_05]: And obviously deliveries are common to the yard, but usually I would guess.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not the one accepting them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think in the past you might have sometimes opened up the gate and if it was like a regular thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you would know maybe one or two of the more regular delivery guys, like by sight, this is not them.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't recognize these guys as like the normal guys that are delivering.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: But do I expect that I have to pay them for delivery?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not normally, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not normally, would you guys pay?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: There might be like a special order type of situation where sometimes you would have to make a payment on delivery, but normally it would be prearranged.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm just expecting them to.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, do you have any delivery papers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are not normally so
[SPEAKER_02]: so uh all about the book like this are you uh he kind of reaches down into his um he reaches down into his like inside his coat for a second uh kind of looking for the paperwork he steps forward to you he pulls out a cudgel and he hits you across the head that's not nice that's not nice at all holy shit so um he is gonna make an attack where is he he's gonna bonk me
[SPEAKER_02]: It will be soon, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good for you being so on the edge.
[SPEAKER_02]: He rolls a 14, that was on the whisper.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does that hit you, Billy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he does too much damage to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not rolling a one on the damage dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's designed to be like one of these one-shot knockout sucker punches.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it doesn't.
[SPEAKER_05]: It doesn't just get knocked out for a bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah but uh he doesn't properly kind of like hit you across the head as he's intending to and you take a hit which basically like if you don't react he will be able to knock you out but you have the ability to like react to this happening because he's not properly like one shot knocked you out as he's intending i guess i'm not really sure what's happening i just feel like i'm attacked yeah clearly yeah um
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess the first instinct would be to create some distance.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. And I'm just thinking, oh, how can I get rid of this guy?
[SPEAKER_05]: And I guess what would happen is that I would cast Thunder Wave.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's from the Magic Initiate feed.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's each creature in a 15-foot cube originating from me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Must make a Constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll just put it in the thingy.
[SPEAKER_05]: So it's a Constitution 12 saving throw.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess it would hit both of them if they're close.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, the range 15 foot cube.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you wanted to, you can hit the cart and therefore the driver and the guy in front of you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, that's going to wreck the car as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: If you want to do that, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would hit everything.
[SPEAKER_05]: Probably that's in the range.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just find the stats for this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: The final part.
[SPEAKER_00]: We hear this happening as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you guys hear the thunder when you go off.
[SPEAKER_02]: So constitution saving for for this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't have to write it down to say you've gone 12.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, yeah, yeah, control of cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's a four on the dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: That guy fails to drive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're throwing silently, by the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm rolling a real dice because they're easier to cheat with.
[SPEAKER_02]: So two fours on the dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you hit both of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can roll damage.
[SPEAKER_05]: And they're getting pushed back 10 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the cards is like 12 damage to those guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just find his health, because he's not that crazy strong.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I think he has more than 12 health.
[SPEAKER_02]: You should know.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, you guys all hear this as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: We will probably roll initiative.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe we don't need to if he just one shots them both.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can we always decide if it's nonlethal or lethal before?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can, but you do need to say if you are attempting to nonlethally.
[SPEAKER_02]: know people that you can, and it is dependent on the ability and like stuff like a fireball.
[SPEAKER_02]: It can't be believed.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I also think even like something like Thunderwave, which is force damage, I think you just don't really have the control over whether the guy breaks his neck on landing or something, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, like with this guy, it's like you're flip, you're literally flipping the card that he's on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you know, if he lands
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I might do a roll to see like if he died like if you reduce him to zero like is he unconscious knocked out or is he actually dead I might decide to make a roll that way in the feet like in these situations, but um, oh my god completely Too many fucking NPCs, which one hit him?
[SPEAKER_02]: The driver yeah, the the older The older guy not the driver.
Yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we don't know who hit him because we don't we didn't see it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you guys don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I mean, yeah, generally.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why am I so unable to find this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Try.
[SPEAKER_01]: You really need to sort the NPCs, Sir Quimson.
[SPEAKER_02]: They are so sorted, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: Apparently not.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you knock out both of these guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: I thought so.
[SPEAKER_02]: They are not particularly strong.
[SPEAKER_02]: You knock them both out, but there is a twist.
[SPEAKER_02]: You throw them back, both of them, and I will roll in front of the board here for some...
[SPEAKER_02]: luck checks for them to see if they die, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you are flinging them with enough force and damage to throw them across a street made of cobbles, full of cobbles, you're throwing the cart with them.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's 10 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Knock back 10 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's 10 feet but it's 12 damage and they have 10 health.
[SPEAKER_02]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, they're not particularly strong.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, they see like this little 19 year old kid and they're just going to like beat up a 19 year old kid.
[SPEAKER_02]: 10 and above they're alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the first guy, this is the not the driver.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guy who was driving was alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: But more importantly than any of this, you smash the cart and the crate that is on the back makes a horrible roar as it takes half damage, having succeeded in its constitution save, and you throw it to the side for it to crash into the ground in the middle of the street, stepping up out of the
[SPEAKER_02]: pieces of the crate is a eight foot tall humanoid creature eight foot yeah made of like flesh um embedded in its chest is a kind of uh
[SPEAKER_02]: greenish glowing essence core, you would you would see it straight away.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it is like dragging one of its hands along the ground as it is just take it like half damage, but it succeeds on its safe, and it will immediately begin to rush you Billy as a result.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think probably we have to end the session there.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you got any secret powers, now it's time to fucking show up, boy.
[SPEAKER_02]: So none of you guys see this creature here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will say that this art, I think, is actually not.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will update the art a little bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: I won't say why specifically, but it's more mechanical looking than this particular thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I was going to say, is it like actual zombie-like or is it like mechanical with like metal moving parts and stuff like that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it looks like an amalgamation of flesh and machine.
[SPEAKER_02]: It looks like a big kind of constructed flesh creature part machine, part flesh creature powered by an essence core.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And these SS cores are held within metal cubes and stuff, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like a metal construct with a core in the middle and then... No, it's embedded in what is mostly flesh in the chest of the creature.
[SPEAKER_02]: then it has like kind of a metal arm and metal legs and like additional augments and it's like faces uh this one is more flesh than it should be um i won't explain why but yeah yeah is this phoenix is this phoenix fate uh who knows so uh this creature starts to rush towards the thing having shattered it's
[SPEAKER_02]: the people that were delivering it or whatever, crushed on the floor, unconscious or dead, but this thing still remains as a threat.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we will pick up from there next time we play.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just realized we haven't had to fight in a while.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's been two sessions ago that we last fought something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and some of you weren't present for that fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, it's definitely a less fight-heavy
[SPEAKER_02]: campaign, just the way that it's run.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it also depends on what you guys do and how successful you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's been a number of situations where you could have ended up in fights, but you did things or avoided them or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that also comes down to you guys and the actions that you take.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was hoping I didn't have to fight in the VIP room.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would have been hilarious.
[SPEAKER_02]: It would have been interesting if Billy had failed to intimidate that mask.
[SPEAKER_02]: That would have been also interesting.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's definitely combat
[SPEAKER_02]: available, but it's more up to you guys than me, whether they happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you initiated the combinator.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's be real.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's true.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_02]: Although you could have
[SPEAKER_02]: You could have also just gone along with his plan, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, obviously.
[SPEAKER_05]: William was just worried that he didn't know how to handle it because his backyard is closed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: From your point of view, you were like annoying work problem where you don't know how to do the paperwork.
[SPEAKER_02]: And from this guy's point of view, you were like stopping him doing whatever he was trying to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so he thinks you're in on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he goes to attack you and you're just like, I don't know how to fill out the paperwork.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you know, he also messed with the wrong delivery boy, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bro just, he whacks him across the head.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bro's like, Oh, I guess I'm going to kill you now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Should we look at the next time we can play?
[SPEAKER_01]: How's next week?
[SPEAKER_03]: Next week, everything except Wednesday works for me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, everything except Thursday.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, Saturday won't work for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, Saturday evening time would work, maybe.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can we play earlier?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, there is open day and I need to be in the Institute for... No, I mean like earlier in the week.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Monday?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can't play Monday, I have to be in the group on Monday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tuesday?
[SPEAKER_02]: Grimm's just like, can you guys give me some...
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Friday?
[SPEAKER_02]: Friday evening?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I can do any day basically next week, but yeah, Friday is fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Friday evening, same day, in a week.
[SPEAKER_02]: Same time, same day.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not longer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Same day, same time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we have some group meeting in the afternoon, but I assume that it should be end by the 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought you were going to say you have another barbecue.
[SPEAKER_00]: Endless barbecue.
[SPEAKER_00]: But some of those or many of the people are from Italian and Argentinian.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they come to work very late and they like to have meetings very late.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I still assume that the meeting should be finished by six o'clock.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, well, let's get to that.
[SPEAKER_02]: That works for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's bring that in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crimson's like, why do they want to play so quickly now?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like he usually was like.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're just about to die.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, why do they want to play now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Crimson's stressing out.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has to prepare stuff ahead of time this time.
[SPEAKER_05]: She was already prepared.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was already prepared.
[SPEAKER_02]: The thing is, every time I'm preparing multiple things, and then when they don't happen, I'm just ending up with like...
[SPEAKER_02]: big backlogs of things that could happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then when one of them does happen, I can't find it because I've got too much food and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I have to be ready for all the various different potential things that you guys might do in certain places at certain times, which is complicated.
[SPEAKER_02]: But, um, but no, it's all good.
[SPEAKER_02]: So good.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can like, once the campaign's over, I would really love to see some of the backlogs that you have, you know, it's like for event or shit that could happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: sure yeah well yeah we'll see we'll see in four years by that point yeah there might not be yeah there might be so much stuff i won't even know what it is i originally had to burn but i wonder if there's anything that is really obviously well i mean one one example would be obviously there's no way for me to know whether or not you guys get caught by the masked man coming out yeah so that can obviously play like so many different ways and even before that when you're doing the
[SPEAKER_02]: persuasion checks and shit to pretend that you're not asking in a room full of bad guys, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: There's like the permutations that are like so many different potential ways.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys have to escape from there?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys just get fucking deleted?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like there's so many ways that those scenes can go.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what are you ready?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll delete all of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's many different ways things can go there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So already that's like, at least some of those, you know, I know can't happen anymore, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like,
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's fine, but yeah, fun times.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thanks, guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did lots of info, lots of talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that's good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's great for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can, yeah, I just get to sit there and listen to you guys talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're doing all the work.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this one is like a lot more lore heavy compared to like the other campaigns that we play.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Every campaign is just like, oh.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't know shit about each other.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: About each other.
[SPEAKER_02]: About the plot in general.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you guys, I will say that one tiny piece of help is that I think you guys know a lot more than you realize you just haven't put it together.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you actually have loads of the information pieces that you need from various times and sources and people.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just haven't connected all the dots yet, which is fair enough because there's a lot going on.
[SPEAKER_03]: Remember Crimson, we didn't solve a puzzle for toddlers in the previous campaign.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's going to take a while.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no fear.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you can just, I would just suggest asking either me or like, or the party in general, whether there are certain things that you know, or that you've forgotten and stuff, it happens quite in the newest critical role campaign, partly because they had this massive break because the DM
[SPEAKER_02]: The DM's wife had a baby, so he took a massive break as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's also super lore heavy, and they often get stuff wrong or have no clue what is going on and stuff, but you just have to kind of like ask.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's like their full-time job to fucking know this stuff, so it's like, you know, they probably should know a lot better than you guys about exactly what's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: Have a good weekend!
[SPEAKER_05]: Bye!